hey everybody
it's been a while since you've seen my
face and I haven't been doing so great
to be totally honest uh
took a little bit of a break
two weeks to be exact
a lot of people have been saying things
about me that aren't really quite true
at all and doesn't matter if it's true
though does it
no
as long as it's entertaining right
you guys having fun
take it away
[Music]
the long come out of you with hateful
accusations toxic gas of train
steam all with someone's reputation
toxic gossip trade hop on board close
your eyes otherwise you realize the
train is made of lies and that person in
Disguise and you didn't deserve to die
but hey
yeah you know
I made this little apology I forgot to
mention a few things but they're not big
deals for example my brother's a
pedophile
forget about that one yeah he was he was
trying to pick up a 14 year old man that
was inappropriate nah I guess it's not
important hey what about that time I was
sending nudes of my friend Trisha Paytas
to 14 year olds
nah nobody cares about that
[Music]
let's talk about this toxic train
listen there's nothing wrong with a
little inflation porn to be honest shout
out dad that one is totally fine to be
honest he didn't he did nothing wrong my
dad is innocent
well that's been fun
especially that time I made kids put
tampons in their mouth to take a groupie
photo with me
not a big deal what's with all this
gossip nah
come on it's not like I was talking
about my sex life with kids talking
about my divorce with kids gossiping
with two children about children trauma
dumping on kids oh yeah and assaulting a
girl on stage it's really not a big deal
it's just a bunch of toxic gossiping man
as long as it's entertaining
[Music]
few with hateful accusations toxic
gossip train
steam all over someone's reputation
toxic acid rain tell me to the tracks
and arrest me for the Past rumors look
like facts when they don't mind the gaps
you won't deserve to die the crashed but
okay
[Music]
yeah but what do I know right
[__] me right
[Music]
you guys wouldn't understand anyway
the worst thing the least worst thing
about it is the inflation part
nothing wrong with the little
gassing up
all right guys well thanks for being
here we've been gone for two weeks and
we got so much to talk about I thank you
all for being here and I look forward to
having a great show
[Music]
let's get right into it
hey
but hey yo
it was amazing
by the way do you guys have a name the
band name
what is it
beaufi
bofi choir
Band On Fire Choir that's what's up that
was amazing you guys
you guys have links we'll put links in
the description so people can we'll put
links in the description so people can
check you guys out and you are beautiful
oh my God that voice is stunning
everything was crushing thank you guys
the band on Fire Choir you guys crushed
it
[Applause]
beautiful
well thank you to the band Ela joining
us here
we are back baby
two weeks is a long time isn't it so
long
man cheers my dude I've missed that you
know where's my dude
this episode is brought to you by
stamps.com thank you and we love them so
much yeah I mean golly we sure missed a
lot in those two weeks and that always
happens you know right
by the way you got everyone knew we had
to do the toxic gossip Train cover so
hopefully we did it justice that was
amazing with the band on fire that was
amazing I want to listen to this later
that's a single yeah that's for that
that's the thing about what Colleen Did
you know I give her points for novelty
for original I have not seen when you
think you've seen it all
and the YouTube apology sphere
should Colleen bus Kicks Down the door
like the Kool-Aid guy and says uh-uh
raising the bar you've got something for
you I got this ukulele here but it's
actually kind of a fire song it's kind
of a Bop I was impressed with her
musical abilities right ignoring uh the
context and everything she's saying and
who she is and all that I was like um
pretty talented good singing
thank you so obviously I I have been
trying to insulate myself
obviously I watched her
um her apology if you could call it that
I don't think it's an apology
so that it's kind of the opposite of an
apology right
yeah this is a new category wait what is
what is the opposite of an apology
Stick It To You doubling down a doubling
Down video this was a dermatologist
melodical Double Down yes melodic Double
Down see that's the new genre and we
have to applaud her at least for for
that right
oh
denial denial yeah maybe a denial but
anyway I've watched it I was so tempted
to make an Ethan Klein video I resisted
the urge because I wanted to come here I
wanted to do it with the gang I haven't
watched anybody's reaction to it because
I wanted to keep it fresh for myself I
know a lot of you guys are probably
tired of hearing about it but you will
not deprive me of the joy and the
content
okay it's not my fault that she had to
drop that [__] the day we went on break
she had to come out here with a ukulele
and [__]
10 minutes on the ukulele 10 [__] you
know 10 minutes my my first reaction
when I was watching it I was like one
minute and I was like okay she's doing a
cute ukulele song but then I was like
wait it's not the whole 10 minutes is it
right the whole 10 minutes was on the
uke
how much rehearsal you think dude how
many hours that thing was very rehearsed
she had buttons on specific words she
had like it was choreographed 100 that's
what was impressive that was like
Broadway ready it was absolutely
horrendous like I don't know as a
performance I thought it was impressive
right but I don't see her on abroad I
don't see that song on a broadcast no
she's off Broadway she was actually once
on Broadway and I did see odd Broadway
or Off-Broadway it was on Broadway she
was on Broadway
um
so true
well anyways I'm glad that y'all are
excited to be here we have 52 000 live
already that's amazing thank you guys
for being here uh thank you everybody
for waiting patiently and uh boy two
weeks has been a long time I'm really
glad to be back so
thank you everybody 14. so much has
happened
who's here oh yeah love is here oh my
God love is here Love Is in the Air oh
yeah
yes um I'm below 200 pounds
I bet I gotta be honest
you gave me that Mayo up the Dome at the
end of the live show and I barely I made
it under 200 but I shouldn't wake up
like 199.5 that works that counts
got a one in the beginning it's got a
one
that's right Cheers Cheers my dude so uh
let's see um
oh another thing I wanted to mention
before we get into all the Colleen stuff
is um
we talked extensively before we went on
break about this conspiracy someone had
about why Alfredo wouldn't go in the
basement right oh my God they said
there's something going on down there he
smells it
and so during the break we went full
Recon down there okay we bought up we
brought a moisture
specialist
we brought the city
the LA gas and Power Defense check we
brought a mold specialist and there were
problems yeah actually first thing we
discovered is that there was like a
major gas leak
yes I don't know if that can cause any
like health because one of the other
theories is that it was affecting
Shredder right
and and explaining why his kidney was
messed up now I don't know if that has
anything to do with it may I hopes I
hope so you know what I mean but yeah
there was when the guy from the city
came they come with these little
instruments and then he he put on the
hot water so the water here would turn
on and I was sitting like uh right
across the door from him and I heard him
go oh my God
really yeah he was like I think it was
it was pretty it must have been really
bad because this is his what he does for
a living and he was
he was a
physically shocked by the gosh yes
yeah but um that probably could have
blown up our house anyway so that's
right did we fix that oh that was scary
yeah
and
I mean Alfredo did come down since that
came down since we fixed the gasoline
this is so crazy there was mold in there
in the in that room too which there
wasn't we looked we had a leak detector
they couldn't find a leak so they think
maybe it was just dry uh old moisture
coming from the ground potentially but
they fixed that okay
and then um I also bought this
industrial uh Power air purifier and an
industrial level air and now analyzer
because somebody said radon it could be
radon
and when I first plugged it in the radon
levels were almost
too high but they've gone down so I I
don't know where it's at yet you know
what I mean but but thank you to whoever
said that because there was definitely
some issues down there
[Applause]
Alfredo is coming down now yeah the
basement yeah he's coming down
unbelievable like he he would never and
then sometimes we would try to bring him
down with us like carrying him down and
then he would immediately run back up
not anymore and now he stays with us
down there yeah
so that was so thank you to you guys
that's so that's kind of been the
project was just yeah tearing apart our
basement
uh and purifying the air there
but um look at all the stuff we missed
I've got a list uh
from the subreddit oh wait where's the
meme that you found the meme love didn't
you
what's up let me share it in this court
let's see here's a list Colleen
Ballinger which obviously is was uh huge
the P the Titanic's uh submersible
exploded underwater rest in peace
um I've been voraciously consuming
anything about that
[Music]
enough
we need to memorialize them
they're right next to Jack man in a
watery grave are you on a Titanic kick
now is that what you were saying that
the submersible kind of no no no but
that's it no I just wanted to understand
what happened we're watching all these
videos where they go over like what was
wrong with the
yeah this vessel and like how they saved
money in building it Rod yeah how they
he didn't want to do any any of the
testing that the regulatory testing that
you need
basically everybody in this like
professional submarine world was like
this is not safe and you're gonna get
somebody killed he's like man [__] that
I'm a Libertarian it's like I don't
believe in rules and regulations he
literally is on record being like I
don't believe in safety checks it just
slows down Innovation meanwhile watery
grave next to Jack in the [__] heart
of the ocean or whatever
so I asked that because Ally because of
the Titanic thing decided to go watch oh
which she loves and I respect because
it's James Cameron and he's the goat
um
yeah exactly I mean come on uh but there
is a right after that we found out
there's a Titanic exhibition here in Los
Angeles with like a bunch of like
Recreations of parts of the boat and
stuff and it was actually really cool
Ali and I went and checked it out you
didn't have to go to the bottom of the
ocean I didn't have to go down the ocean
and at the very end of the museum thing
or whatever they had a TV set up with a
memorial for the dumbass they knew why
everyone was there so I mean it is
really sad though because the guy was
such a piece of [__] and he 100 murdered
all those people yeah and then the
people on there I feel horrible about
especially this one guys 19 year old son
yeah reportedly didn't even want to go
on this he was scared to go right except
for his dad as a Father's Day present
God damn well did you hear the the mom
came out and she was like No No I gave
him my spot and then people gave her
hate for that too oh so that poor Mom
I'm sure she feels great about that God
I can't can't even think about that
suffering so much yeah but I mean and
the good the good news is that
they died
so fast that their brains and couldn't
even have the time to process what was
happening that's true they just stopped
existing
basically so that's good that's a good
way to die I think I guess I don't know
um so apparently what was happening they
were halfway down and they started
hearing cracking oh my God you like that
yeah they weren't even all the way down
oh God that's halfway and then they so
they started they tried going reversing
and going back up and they the ship was
such a piece of crap it just exploded
so they were definitely terrified on the
web whatever time they had left lovely I
didn't know that yeah
terrifying little detail yeah there's a
there's there's the
the call that the command had up on this
boat
you can hear it where they lost touch
they were typing or somebody narrated
they were typing to each other and it's
like report in reporting uh we're
hearing cracks reporting reporting and
then they just stopped responding wow
very sad uh but the guy who did that's
total piece of [__] and that is why um
libertarianism is a that's why it's a
disaster guys
let's just not be a Libertarian please
you might just wind up gonna kill you
floated on the bottom of the ocean gonna
kill you
yeah so here's all the stuff we missed
Jimmy calling a fan of fat [__] which
yeah and another I mean yeah the live
show was phenomenal yeah we never
debriefed about the live show can you
guys pull up the Jimmy War when he
started throwing a badges that were
magic
the live show was so much fun it was the
last show we did of the uh
of the run there
and it was so fun and thank you guys to
everybody who painted him I think it was
a very wholesome very fun event I gotta
say uh Howie Mandel was there now
treasure Legend crushed it I'm not gonna
read it
oh boy are we ready
that was everything dude that is the
sound right into it
I'm a legend dude that sounds gonna read
it [__] you
that sound bite is gonna get so much
mileage before the end of the year oh
poor guy anytime we're talking about
like essay or something dodgy show us
photography oh Maui
inappropriate bro you want to see that
Holly
show us child pornography uh this
although this was my favorite moment uh
Jimmy was promised a to have a 20-minute
set yes because he co-hosted with me
when we had Sebastian that Tick Tock
alpha male on right and he was
phenomenal right we thought he was going
to get kicked off but he blasted the
whole oh he nailed it he was great and
so uh he got his moment
but we knew that there was probably
gonna have to be a little bit of an edge
to make it more enjoyable for the
audience
and so we ordered uh 500 uh tomatoes
from China is that right was it five we
were gonna go 500 yeah
we were gonna get a thousand but the the
actual volume of that wasn't so insane
yeah those tomatoes are very cute by the
way yeah everyone got to take them home
as souvenirs that was really cool
I think they might be apples but uh
pretty sure they were apples I think we
got conned it looks like a tomato we got
foisted Apple I like that they were
pretty big that was fun yeah yeah so um
it turned it was so funny oh my God it
was so funny here let me give you guys a
taste and
[Music]
[Applause]
we started turning on a big time
all love and strength in which he helped
her own so well my God what did you eat
for dinner
will you stop
Jersey outlaw
okay wait wait wait now hold on let's
get the hell down you're right faster
stand up young fella there's a guy right
here stand up
sometimes the circus goes sure you want
to get closer Jimmy you're gonna catch a
beard last in your face don't get too
close man they were out for blood you're
gonna work the cotton candy machine
and look at this guy stand up
yeah you want a banana
my God he looks like a gorilla Jesus
Christ
my God he was you know why why does he
think he can do those jokes he's a Jimmy
Lee man we've been through it and he
comes he does the same material yeah
uh but he he actually I've never seen
him just be like fat [__] to somebody
[Laughter]
nobody's throwing Tomatoes up how you
doing big guy how you doing he pointed
out uh yeah
when you sweat you sweat marinara sauce
where you stop that's a good job
my God you guys are killing how dare you
come for Avery yeah all right Jimmy wait
let's reset let's reset I'll give you
more time I'll give you more time I got
to get to the part where he started uh
fighting back yeah
this is when I went come back on the
show
I told Sam stop with the tomatoes here
it is
iconic
and in a Martin nowhere yeah
I can't emphasize let me mute it I can't
emphasize how out of nowhere Martin I
did not expect him to be there I saw him
and then he's like okay I'm part of the
show now yeah on stage
um I do want to say to the to the girls
in the front row that Jimmy was uh
harassing thank you for being good
sports everybody was a good sport about
it hopefully nobody had hard feelings
about it it's just Jimmy you know what I
mean Jimmy's pretty spry for an 80 year
old
you know he's you know donut count out
the old horse you know and you know he's
a 90s kid so he's you know oh right
forgive me yeah yeah
he's 43 please he's just one year older
than me no you're 43 now nasty do you
know I'm 38. stop this is the news
generic rubbers because he's a cheap
[__]
yeah so anyway it was it was so much fun
and uh I'll tell you I was on stage next
to Jimmy and I could tell he was trying
to hurt them but he was angry he was
throwing those Tomatoes hard he was he
was I was I was pissed at Jimmy because
when he walked out he totally snummed me
I had my hand out he just walked right
by him
for you Zack
well I saw him in the back and he was
sitting around there's like five guys
like Fanning him he goes Amy what just
happened out there I'm like I I don't
know Jimmy you tell me what just
happened he's like was it good I was
like yeah yeah no it was better than it
did it was iconic it was so fun it was
literally my favorite part
stop with the tomatoes I mean I went
back and watched that one a few times it
was so fun but yeah shout out to the
girls in the front row who are good
sports we love y'all
but um yeah I'm thinking we should put
on our tickets for the next live pretty
soon Dan we should lock it down and get
it going sure yeah yeah I'm planning on
getting the ball rolling on all that
this week
oh Jimmy even apologized he said
everyone I hey everyone I definitely
defiantly went to too far saying fat
[__] I know now that is completely
unacceptable
I was never meant to harm or hurt her
she is family and we are here for each
other
so much was happening and I went a bit
crazy my apologies go out to her and no
hard feelings okay okay we love that
some the top comments Jimmy we aren't
mad your left was on the line and that's
technically true he was fighting for
survival in that moment
let's see uh can we go on the two-week
break Colleen drops the apology idubbbz
lost 250k on Creator Clash that yeah
that was unfortunate Colleen's oh dude
that was a huge Revelation that she was
sending right that Trisha the nudes
nudes to minors and also she was while
being a friend of hers it was recently
because when I first saw it I was like
is this from like a long time ago oh
it wasn't
and they were they started this podcast
together I frankly felt bad for Trisha I
mean that's a horrible thing to discover
that your supposed friend's been doing
like hey you got a load of hers isn't
she nasty
while doing a show with her yeah yeah oh
yeah and Trisha made a response video
which guys I got to tell you that was a
huge moment for the Internet it's been a
long time she wasn't on the kitchen
floor anything she was she held herself
together pretty well she leveled up
actually she did level up Amy saves some
balls
yeah what was that what was that I
I didn't even see that in this meme
these uh my cousins were throwing a
volleyball oh yeah so I keep getting it
right you and obviously you cut the part
where he was you throwing them right
put your balls in my mouth sure
interesting
cocaine in the White House Gabe goes
full Uncle okay idea I was not aware of
this wait wait what is that shock up in
there I don't know what when did this
happen I don't know I I I haven't seen
it I don't know anything about it says
Gabe goes Uncle full uncle and drops F's
what the what I didn't see that no way
anywhere oh Gaby what are you doing I
didn't see it I saw people mentioning it
but I didn't I don't know what it is so
oh here's Oh Martin uh posted a clip
let's see what Marty boys here
hello everybody
oh God he's such a legend I love that
man I was like what the hell he's like
the man just takes control he's like
give me a mic
just give me the mic I was like all
right
there it is the water drops of bliss
and so um
yeah so much that's been going on Remus
the shake thing which I'm happy not to
talk about what uh the Grimace purple
Shake McDonald's thing yeah not a big
deal the advertisement yeah everyone
fell for uh Travis Scott not charged
that's a shame World War III talk with
Russia Twitter shutting down yeah
Twitter limiting the frame rates on
people was pretty good that was
ridiculous
I'm officially a thread head by the way
give it up I've been Mass posting to
threads because like as much as I hate
Zuck all right I hate Facebook and all
everything they stand for and do yeah I
also hate Elon Musk and everything he's
doing yeah and you know Elon Musk he
always says this he thinks it's very
profound he goes whatever's the funniest
outcome is the most likely to happen
have you seen him say that he thinks
it's really important I haven't seen
that so I says well undoubtedly the
funniest outcome is you losing 44
billion dollars and having to shut
Twitter and disgrace right so that's why
I'm on
threads
I've been off of Twitter already for a
while
it's kind of nice for me to have a
Instagram version I get the hate though
we have some haters here in the office
for Threads yeah it's not there yet it's
fun though the one thing we're just
goofing and gaffing I'm free there I
mean like morally obviously I feel
weirder on Twitter than I do on threads
however if I say something and I'm like
wow that's so funny I want people to
look at it and so the No No
I can't cross post are you kidding
seriously oh my God I'm not literally
you posted it on threads this morning
Olivia yes I did but I would never cross
post the same thing really you have
exclusive that's a big number
okay I agree with you that I love I love
the [__] threads I hate Twitter thank
you I'm both threaded I'm listening
listening to threads Reddit threads up
the only thing thread is missing
currently is the trending tab because I
go there for
versus threads which is just like
you never know where that goes well
here's the thing the more time I spent
on Twitter recently it's just unusable
it's unusable the bot I've never seen so
many Bots crypto scams never and
literally every like any any tweet that
goes even remotely viral you go to the
replies and you have to scroll
through
like 500 of the dumbest people on the
[__] planet that have the [__]
blue check mark yeah they're all not
it's just it's just Nazis yeah blue
check mark Nazi like it's just it's not
even worth it it's horrible it's never
been worse whatever I haven't yeah I'm
off Twitter I love Hitler what
about Hitler
so Dan is on thread so that's reason
enough right thank you
is like the biggest Joy you you've got
good threads today he's talking to JLo
this morning I haven't seen that High
Street Dan has good threads I agree
you guys were able to connect like that
yeah I'm gonna pull ups Dan has been
crushing it absolutely I'm gonna post
them up word
you're loving threads Dan what are you
I'm talking about you never even tweet
and now you go JLo's a crystal mommy
yeah well look at this look at this
thread that JLo said she goes money more
days Monday morning thread I learned
recently that hummingbirds flap their
wings in a figure eight motion which
represents Infinity
what's something you've recently learned
yeah I don't think the hummingbird is
doing it I don't think the hummingbird I
don't think it represents anything it's
just a way of moving yeah yeah yeah
the hummingbird don't you see
oh my God there's a vortex at the center
of the figure eight of the hummingbirds
transcends time oh yeah this this
cracked me up too Dan um
so the CEO of cloudflare
posted stats that Twitter's
traffic is tanking and Dan treated too
quoted it and you said concerning
and I thought that was concerning I was
concerned about that
so that's it you know uh let's see what
else
Selena Gomez used my sound
and listen as much as I love my girl
Gomez Daddy needs to get paid right
don't even look at me right now are you
kidding me it was the first thing out of
literally you didn't give us time to
bask in it you were like oh wait rare
Beauty posted that well we were during
break well how are you gonna be so true
yeah we need some Revenue during the
break I just yeah hello
I was so excited and people were tagging
me in it like the entire break and I
knew that we're about to be enemies
she's not even gonna find out I'm just
gonna shake down her [__] makeup
company and they can afford to make it
they can afford it they can they are
doing very well they're a very
successful very successful woman just
throw me a couple hundred thousand and
we don't have to talk about it anymore
right a couple hundredk well then
another angle was I told my lawyer well
tell them you know if she wants to if
she wants to come on the show we'll let
bygones be bygones
agree we love her it's so true but also
I'm suing you yeah
not really suing well if she doesn't pay
up y'all I'll have to take her to court
girl I'm sorry dude are you kidding you
can't use my voice to sell products oh
you can't take Selena Gomez to court
it's not her it's rare Beauty okay but
but that's your company though that is
her I'll never get a PR package well
maybe I'll have to dispose depose her
then and maybe when I depose her maybe
when I depose her over this lawsuit I'll
start asking her a question about Justin
Bieber yeah and Haley
I remind you Selena you are under o
right right
um
here it is also
[Music]
I don't know okay girl first of all this
is posted from the rare Beauty Tick Tock
account with Selena Gomez in it text is
when someone asks me what product I used
in my brows and I remember my new rare
Beauty brow pencil hasn't launched yet
this is so commercial the use of this is
so commercial such a smart it's such a
slam dunk for me
we are in such a fight you and me listen
I got you I have to enforce my um
how do you call it my uh morals oh
there's a there's a legal use to my
personality likeness I have to enforce
my my likeness you know I can't be if
they want to use me they got to pay up
thank you Selena we love you girl
you know what I mean we're never meeting
her
um so moving on here love do you want to
do the spicy chip thing today is that
something we want to do because I Love
Actually I could do that I'm sure are we
doing can I maybe give him a reprieve I
don't did love tell you what happened to
him this morning
um no what happened
I did almost break my hand yeah he had a
bit of a boo-boo this morning I was in a
lot of pain yeah and so what are you
eating it with your hand why do I
who knows this was just done no I'm
kidding what happened why does it still
hurt yeah yeah it might be broken what
happened uh I was carrying up boxes and
when you have a box in your hand
you can't really see what's on the floor
and when I came up the stairs I just ate
[__] over something that was on the
floor with the heavy boxes and I got my
hand stuck under the box when I hit the
floor so so
you are you trying I mean I'm not trying
I didn't bring that up I was yeah this
is all this was just me feeling bad for
him so I mean listen we have a lot to
get to so I might be okay moving the
spicy chip to Wednesday so that's true
yeah maybe my finger will be unbroken
Wednesday yeah no no I'm kidding I'll do
it whenever it fits the show so as we
just have some okay so maybe we'll move
it to Wednesday because we just have so
much to talk sure sure
um yeah and actually
um we're at break time oh wow oh that
was fast so we only have one sponsor so
guys stick around I'm gonna thank our
sponsorstamps.com and we're gonna come
back talk about a couple other things
that are really fun
for example Jason Nash was asked about
Frenemies during a comedy show you will
not believe what he said
you will not believe it so stay tuned
uh but anyway let's thank our sponsor
real fast steps.com we love stamps.com
man yes we do
champs.com is the best in the game if
you are mailing anything if you're just
a personal
person or person or running a business
from home or even if you're a freaking
huge business stamps.com is the solution
for you you got to make every penny
count when it comes to business okay
stamp stops cheers samsung.com gets it
because for the last 25 years they've
been helping businesses Like Yours save
time and money okay why do you use
stamps.com one you don't have to go to
the Post Office it's super convenient
two
they work with so many people they get
up to 84 off USPS and UPS rate 84 that's
ridiculous have you tried mailing
something recently like out of state or
God forbid International or I don't
think I don't know if this is
international but maybe it is
but it's insanely expensive it's so
expensive you know it cost us more to
get the tomatoes here than it did to pay
for the tomatoes isn't that right
correct tomatoes tomato Tomatoes is the
proper pronunciation stop throwing the
tomatoes
yeah so you get fat discounts and here's
how it works they send you a free scale
okay then you weigh the package the
envelope whatever you're sending you
print it the postage from your computer
you put it on the package they come and
get it
they come get it from your house they
come get it from your mailbox or you can
go to a Dropbox it's so convenient it's
cheaper why are you not using stamps.com
right
why they've been in business for 25
years and they're helping over 1 million
businesses okay I love you
love ya sign up at stamps.com
Zach you couldn't wait to ride those man
uh sign up at stamps.com h3tv for a
special often includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com slash
h3tv thank you so much to stamps we love
you thank you Stan consider supporting
our sponsor stamps yes thank you
uh real quickly also do you want to talk
on Thursday we have attention so
Thursday there's a new release I love a
lot of it so here's one t-shirt till
that do us part A lot of the stuff I
like has green and I can't wear green on
the show yeah but these guys Dan is
wearing a cool new striped shirt
um Olivia is wearing this really cute
halter top it has
um four buttons in the back and it's
kind of like
um you could do it smaller or bigger so
it's a size oh inclusive and then a B's
got this
um
uh I forget the name of Hickory stripe
it's like a windbreaker silhouette
but um not from nylon it's um it's this
really nice Hickory is that what it's
called I'm not like a wood I think
that's what it's called unless my brain
is having a moment Hickory Dickory
um ew love
wearing oh striped shirt that one's a
hit it's nice
got the cardigan that I've been obsessed
with I'm already wearing it like every
day now it's such a nice material and I
got the matching fake bird too
um leany leany
she's got this cute uh women's bear top
with like a little ribbon
and then where is he in there I can't
see him Ian was wrong okay so Ian's got
the this pets t-shirt and it's also on a
crew neck and these are all animals of
people at the office we've got Shredder
and Alfredo there too and Ian's
um cat right
yeah yeah there's a lot of um wait Ian's
cats made the cut yeah what about Dan
was he trying my chopped flavor yeah you
provided the photos I don't know oh that
was probably Sam a Sam connection yeah
yeah yeah
there's a there's a few collar shirts
that I love yeah I'll have to wear them
on on Friday Friday
um I don't know I don't think Zach is
wearing 31st today right exactly I I
have the shirt we had a very busy
morning and I didn't mean to change into
it so I do apologize
it's got a fire shirt though he has
official unlicensed uh official
unofficial unofficial unlicensed uh
Hannah Silence of the Lamb by the way
Ian is also wearing the carpenter pants
of the same fabric of ab's top yeah
those are still they're cool
all right so yeah this Thursday this is
not part of the draw but I when um when
cam made this edit I really wanted it on
a shirt
well this is since the last time Oliver
was here he kept was stealing [__] and
causing trouble so this pictures this
picture's up all over our office yes
okay
all right thank you thank you so a
couple a couple of things we'll hit on
real fast before we do uh Colleen this
was a big story that was yeah here it is
if you guys want to put this up in your
house
you can save it
print it
bumper stickers whatever whatever you
need to do put it please put it up
everywhere have you seen this dumbass
call security immediately if seen on
premise
yeah
exactly this this blew my mind Taurus
carves their name into Coliseum and
um I'm absolutely gobs gobsmack but this
man is doing this
there's a whole ass crowd his girlfriend
is sitting there watching
and he's just smile does this guy not
know that
what's the dude why are you hating
what's wrong with him here he's carving
their initials into the Coliseum Stone
like look at him he's like so [__]
awesome he's like yo I had this great
idea
look at this awesome idea I had
love you babe
I like that his girlfriend also doesn't
seem to have an issue with this very
interesting
yeah
[Music]
what a guy
I'm happy to announce that he is was not
American right we
for once
it wasn't a problem do we know let's see
I he said he put out a statement I admit
what the deepest embarrassment that only
after what regrettably happened I
learned of the Antiquity of the monument
why are you at the Coliseum
why did you put it there then
hold on hold on this was built when
Italians I love the Italians
but also dumb because he's like yeah if
if it was like a public space that was
that was new then it would be fine to
carve my initials are you 12 and then by
posting it on Tick Tock are you gonna
get like arrested is it illegal probably
it's got to be illegal yeah for sure
they actually make you fight in the
Coliseum as punishment if you do that
that's fun yeah they give you a spirit
awesome they say good luck as the Lions
charge
um there's uh details about I think he
was facing like a fat ten thousand
dollar fine
uh if convicted of a crime the man could
face a fine of 15 000 Euros sixteen
thousand dollars and five years in
prison
oh my God you know what's the irony
he'll go to jail for five years and his
girlfriend's gonna leave him
because she's like I'm not sticking
around for five years
do we know where he was from oh this
isn't new it says the incident occurred
in 2020. it was a similar incident
happened in 2012. okay okay similar
incident happened when the Irish
damn the Irish
Irish Taurus was accused of vandalizing
the Coliseum after surgery staff spotted
him allegedly carving his initials into
the ancient structure so what happened
to the Irish guy he was never heard from
again
uh
you see
uh yeah
oh we have a whole nother uh Lizzie in a
box
part of the part of the Great uh
Classics oh he's from England
this new guy was from England yeah oh
the UK I mean Little America these guys
really got to get their [__] together
over there I told you and you know
they're always being like Oh Americans
so uncultured
they're uncultured okay well your ass is
you know what I mean this is a
referendum on all English people
everything ivory
Ali G isn't even that dumb I'm dreaming
of my next Tucker
so there it is we salute the English
today
have a pint hey let's carve our initials
in the Coliseum and have a pint smoko
not a great accent admittedly
uh we have some Steven Crowder stuff
which is awesome as you know he recently
was abusing his wife what caused this
huge divorce yeah watch it that doesn't
work for me either no
um so and he's a massive uh homophobe
and transphobe it's part of like he's
riding that whole wave and as you know
one of his favorite activities is
dressing up as a woman
and then infiltrating Pride events
but what's funny is that he's he's
actually he's just participating
he's just doing Pride it's he's not even
it's not even ironic anymore like uh
there's some new clips here which are
really fantastic watch this and you tell
me where's what you tell me where's the
parody
[Music]
that sexual objectification is bad
unless women do it tits are fun bras do
legitimately suck not gay Jared to
surprise here he is kissing
and not Day Jared is someone who works
for him who is gay right
I think so I think he is gay yeah and so
here he is and I'm sorry but this isn't
a pride event but what is it this was
like the women's March so like there's
really no reason like there's no whoa
he's not even on brand no actually I'm
not but so so he not the not that you
know lesbians wouldn't be welcome there
but it's like
why are you you didn't need to do that
here's where it gets
he went to this March
to show how crazy they are
in doing so he got in full
his drag derogatory can I say drag no
he's in drag yeah so he got in drag with
his gay friend and kissed him
at that women's March
though I mean he really thought about
the outfit I feel like because
it doesn't look like a bad costume you
know he did this for fun yeah yeah now
one of the pleasure one of the things
that people speculate against Crowder is
that he is gay and that kind of is why
he is the way he is and he he's even
said that he had a bisexual phase in
college and I think
that you know his love for Jesus is he
needs to
he can love Jesus in other ways
there's more than one way to love Jesus
didn't it also come out that he was
constantly showing his junk to his yeah
yeah just whipping it out putting his
balls on you guessed it this guy yep not
gay Jared
but homo but like as someone who's like
homophobic and transphobic doing this
this is not a parody this is just you
kissing your homie good night like don't
you see this is not this is just you
being participating but him can see
everyone but I don't understand how his
fans watch this and be like God got him
how did you become gay
the surprisingly good kisser A twice
he says he's a good kisser
surprisingly good kisser what the hell
Trump wants to infringe upon women's
rights but we're not exactly sure which
right something something let's see
but what did we accomplish well not a
whole lot either awesome man well I know
what we accomplished you getting to live
out your fantasy yeah being a woman and
making out with uh your homie I mean
really
and filming it all somehow and felt good
your fans think that this is a own of
liberals somehow well it is it's so good
to go on downstairs they're holding
hands don't feel owned right now wait
wait wait what
yeah did Jared just grab his yeah are
you embarrassed Ethan do you feel owned
hold the [__] phone here hold on to
your phone [__] got you
so we're grabbing dick to own the lips
is it possible
a couple I mean they both seem
very like comfortable it's a divorce I
mean Jared has a wife and two kids I
believe
oh wait so he's not he's not gay okay
Jared not he's not gay but he's calling
him
okay Jay Jared now if you I I don't know
would you feel uncomfortable if you saw
me making out with my homemade and
grabbing dick or do you would you think
that's cool
I'm genuinely curious if this is
crossing some kind of line because like
there's there's a lot of making out and
Dick grabbing the dick grabbing is
actually throwing me off quite a bit
this man just literally grabbed his dick
go on down I wouldn't be wondering like
hey are you having too much fun here
yeah so we need to unpack this I know I
would wonder what the [__] is this
what the hell is this Stephen
why
multiple and then this is also a great
Point multiple children can be seen
watching one of the things that they
always say is uh [__] watch it uh
protect the kids from these drag these
drag people the gay people there
and he's out here grabbing dick with
kids around when nobody else is doing it
as far as I can tell no he didn't get
anyone he literally said what do we
accomplish nothing holy
holy [__]
so amazing and just to clarify for
anybody that was confused yeah this
video is from several years ago it just
no no it was under everybody's radar it
just recently resurfaced and has been
making the rounds
from now or not before we got into it
with him you know pre-divorous okay
pre-divorce pre-stamp Cedar but um yeah
I had never seen it yeah and it really I
was just mind blown
that uh that's owning the libs
hey uh you want to go to fistfest with
me and own the libs Dan
we can show them
go go what would the conservative
inverse be like if we went to CPAC and
like
hell
yeah
sick Heil to own the conservatives yeah
oh man so that was pretty good Jason
Nash this is this is this is tea
uh this is this isn't on video so this
is just the account and I will say the
one time that either of us had an
interaction with Jason you met him and
he was very sweet
so yeah I haven't talked about it on the
show but we did run into each other oh
we haven't post
Ed
the drama and everything so it was very
nice and
it felt like we were like trauma bonded
a little bit Yeah and um it was very
short because if we were in the it was
just the break between a show like it
was a bathroom breaks it was very short
but very nice and respectful and
yeah I think he actually was really
sweet he even can I say he was very
sweet can I say that he
that he wanted to talk more or what if
he said if you want to talk more and
gave you his contact he gave him his
number but I never followed up the
trauma
I I feel like I probably would want to
talk to him about
him about it also at the same time I've
been just kind of like it's been better
for me to just put this behind me and
not talk about it to anybody really
because
it's like I feel better when I don't so
I I haven't opened up that door yet I
don't know I don't know if I will but
yeah it was very nice it was nice and
obviously Jason's uh his problematic
stuff so it's like better to just kind
of steer clear and stuff with the Seth
with all the stuff Seth stuff and all
that
but he was nice that's all I'm saying so
they said last night Jason did his first
show on a comedy tour in Boston during a
set he messed
mentioned Trisha driving into his house
and mentioned David in the Vlogs but
didn't go further into any of it at the
end he did a q a segment where the
audience asked very boring questions
like what's a piece of advice you have
for upcoming YouTuber I soon realized no
one was going to ask anything good shout
out fam I decided to say something his
daughter and mother were on stage with
him for the Q a portion his fiancee was
the one walking through the audience
with the microphone there was time for
one more question I flagged her down she
held the mic for me and I asked Jason on
a scale of one to ten how relieved were
you and for enemies ended I mean that's
kind of a good funny quote I mean it's
not that bad right
is that an inappropriate question I mean
I don't know
the crowd was silent I feel like people
would have laughed at that
and Jason's sort of uh laughed and said
so relieved so relieved that was the
worst time of my life the vibe got
awkward so I mumbled into the mic I'm
glad you got through it and he looked
straight into my soul in a very serious
voice and said they'll get what's coming
to them
foreign
then he changed his tone instead of the
audience okay we need to end on a happy
question
they'll get
what's coming I was like about me what
did I I mean I didn't do anything Jason
don't put epox on my house I don't know
because I had the personal interaction
with him I have a feeling it's not about
us today though who's they when you say
Frenemies right but there's no recording
of this no this is just one and that's
why I say there's just one person's
recount this was at a comedy show I
could see it's a deadpan I could see
that being a dead banjo yeah yeah right
yeah me too
okay he's forgiven
we letting you off the hook this time
Jason
um
patrons ignore robber at nail salon oh
this came out recently this was pretty
amazing this guy's trying to rob them
and dude look at my okay these guys
installed a Chrome extension
that puts Mr Beast
and every thumbnail I am so sad because
I saw this over the break I was like it
was so [__] funny to put this on
Ethan's computer
when the show is about to start I was
going to look at our thumbnail title to
make sure everything was looking good
and I was like wait
I was like who did this and then I was
like wait Mr Beeson all of them and then
when you fresh it it changes the image
but then I was like wait is this
actually a good idea to do for your
thumbnail put them in everything I mean
you know oh my God
who's this
this isn't Mr Beast who is that oh huh
that's fake Mr B says love Yeah AI Cameo
okay I'm glad he made the cast Mr yeast
is there a yeast infection
um anyway here's a little fun thing and
then after this we'll get into Colleen
wait so this extension is something you
can install yeah just a Chrome extension
and it just when you go to YouTube I'm
so sad that he saw it before the show
because I really wanted him to get
confused wow there's some really funny
results like look at this one woman
attacking people with metal pipes
fatally shot by police
oh my God
and that looks that looks great the one
above it is also funny how he's like
kind of serious in that face wild
high-speed chase of stolen Jaguar
through La I saw this one on Twitter I'm
sending it in chat right now that's like
if you expanded into news based news
oh no I was so sad to hear this but
Grace held that's hell big he says she
has breast cancer and obviously we we
support her yeah absolutely and wish her
the best but Mr Beast I mean
inappropriate this is however I was
wearing a suit though he suited up yeah
that's not appropriate and we wish you
well Grace this isn't a chestnuts moment
don't play the chestnuts on Zach thank
you and we wish her well that's horrible
I was like damn
so here's this and then afterwards we'll
do our our story
these ladies are cold man
icy icy veins
[Music]
he answered the phone he's just on the
phone he goes hello
what is this everybody give me
everything
she's just like you wanna give me she's
opening she's opening the door for him
he said [__] this this is so good that
is why poor guy yeah you tried oh my
gosh pretty amazing huh
wow they could have at least given him
something let's see what Mr Beast thinks
about it yeah let me see if Mr Beast is
in this thumbnail
Gwinnett County officer saves choking
man at Golden Corral
uh
God this [__] this is the funniest
plugin ever trying to find the robbery
one after choking on Grape
eight-year-old boy left unable to
communicate
oh my God okay
oh no that poor child a grape
get it off my screen by the way always
cut your grapes in half right but I
didn't know you had to do it for
eight-year-old [__] beast that's [__]
up dude
foreign
I'm not laughing at that that is
horrible no that's horrible arrest made
and shooting of off-duty Gwyneth D.A
office investigator I just I feel like
this would actually be the thumbnails
that he would make if you were to make
those videos I think he needs to get
into the news category yeah
I'm I'm living for these actually let's
see police report explains how South
Fulton mayor got arrested at stranger's
home but you'll get a free iPhone at the
end
Georgia Lemonade Stand X legalizes
miners selling certain products on
private area
please lemonade
I need lemonade
all right well fantastic we love it
folks don't we women take in a hospital
after tree falls on her house
[Applause]
oh man that's good what happened there
where he's got the hand on his head
that's good water could be turned off at
Clayton County apartment complex oh no
that's annoying what is going on there
good question Beast
two dead one injured following multiple
overnight shooting in Atlanta I guess
the the houses are cheap oh
holy [__] this rules maybe this is a
good way to consume news though you know
no not the grape kid again
hold on hold on it's a little [__]
questionable that they're using that
image of him that poor child after
choking on Grape eight-year-old boy left
unable to communicate they they double
posted the story it's in a rough shirt
why'd they put him in a ref shirt
he's like that grape is offsides
I'm calling a red card on that grape
that's horrible
I like how dare is covering the end so
it's just like EU which one
the one next to the poor kid
oh yeah yeah
all right there it is
[__] man it really is a beast all right
well at this point I believe it's time
I'm gonna do a bathroom break
I need to pee too yeah um
real quick right I just wanted to shout
out uh
a person named All Aboard who donated I
think 100 subbies members thank you guys
also I want to say that first of all
thank you to our beautiful members our
wonderful members we will be doing a
members uh
uh stream tomorrow back on schedule now
the break's over so I'll see you guys
there tomorrow
what the [__]
this guy Jersey Lawman is killing me
hold on you got it I love the Jersey
line you gotta pull this up
[Applause]
[Music]
um
hold on here check out this true crime
uh
website or this channel it's really cool
Tina allegedly strangles X on graduation
trip no no no no no yikes murder of
college athletes leads to execution oh
man
Delphi murder updates let's make
allegedly confessed to stabbing that is
so [__] up
we are currently this one is too much
mother accused of killing her four
babies pardoned Jesus really in the
Willy Wonka outfit
apparently it was 200 subbies uh by the
way from All Aboard thank you guys so
much I appreciate you so glad to be back
thank you to 74 000 people who are
watching us live that's fantastic that's
amazing wow so we're gonna get into the
uh the PowerPoint now
we basically have and I'm going to be
reacting to the apology I've watched it
one time I'm going in as virgin as I can
go perfect
all aboard
so that's actually her saying that
yeah yeah yeah I really my favorite part
I've been just shouting it in the
apartment with Ali hey Zach as we wait
you want to play your version of the
song I'll go to the bathroom you play
Zach made a cover that's really
fantastic thank you all right uh yeah
here we go
hello
[Music]
dream
diamond
time it could hurt harass me for my Past
rumors look like bags if you don't find
the gaps I won't survive the crash hi
everyone I've been wanting to come
online and talk about a few things even
though my team has strongly advised me
not to say what I want I won't say I
recently realized though they never said
I couldn't sing what I want to say so
here I am
[Music]
you gotta
go a little station toxic got some
trains
[Music]
some information station
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you thank you
it was a lot of fun
took me all of five minutes to learn
three words
amazing work Zach thank you I would love
to see you live are you playing any live
shows oh matter of fact Zach Lewis live
in San Diego can't wait to see you I
love you Cam I appreciate that
where in San Diego it's called the soda
bar soda bar
soda bar in San Diego
we're in San Diego
all right
how does it feel to be here love uh it
feels weird okay I'm not gonna use to it
yeah
I haven't gotten used to like even being
in La yeah so the Studio's even even
weirder well I we didn't mention it but
loves living in our backyard right yes
oh yeah we have a we have a pool house
detached from the house that loves
staying in yes sir and you're a
fantastic house guest yeah you you know
what I mean you're welcome to stay as
long as you need yeah thank you Ethan
did you know that on I think it was on
4th of July your mom text me a photo of
love
like a smiley face what yeah it was a
photo of love in your pool and your mom
sent it to me it was just like having a
great time over at the client's house
hey you wish you were here
I mean I was happy to get it I'm not I'm
not sure why not I guess she's just
thinking of you like you're you're the
dad I think she wanted to send it to the
crew because we were talking about I was
gonna head to the crew later and she was
like oh I just got that I see yeah I
think that's kind of the train of
thought you guys ever see him like I
don't know like one in the morning he's
like at the refrigerator or anything
like that no honestly I barely see you
yeah you've been busy well I've been
busy and I've also I sneak in
no I mean he doesn't need to go through
the house yeah yeah I own purp you know
because you guys are so gracious letting
me stay there I I do like sneak in and I
don't want to bother you guys well at
all you are gone
I was like hey love are you there
because we're gonna use the pool and I
don't want to like walk in on you he's
like I'm not I've been gone for two days
I was like wow okay yeah yeah
oh
your mom sent me this and you can see at
the bottom and just said we are all
swimming at the Clines that's pretty
funny
the pool is that's very nice cheers
[Music]
um
yes also I'm get oh God I'm getting the
end my endoscope I don't know how you
call it is it endoscopy endoscopy people
were making fun of me last time the
first time
first one he said endoscopy and
endoscopy yeah endoscopy because I feel
like that's what I was saying and then
people were making fun of me they're
like oh
it's hurting me to hear them say it like
that I'm saying endoscopy anyway that's
tomorrow and I'm a little bit
well you're doing that tomorrow I think
yeah wait hold on yeah let me look when
because
right good point it's not gonna like
make it hard to talk
I don't know does it I don't think so
okay no oh really maybe you've done it
before right yeah I was fine oh but I
was really well not me but some other
people that were waiting with me they
were very dizzy right after theirs dizzy
like a couple hours oh wow because they
put you they put you under that's what
I'm confused about you say you're kind
of awake but not like I don't want to be
awake at all no you're knocked out okay
good oh okay I'm telling them I'm like
is there any preparation or you just go
sorry what was that baby
I think you're not supposed to eat or
drink
um a certain time before going that's it
people are saying it's endoscopy
endoscopy actually you know what can you
check on that Lena if I need if I'm not
supposed to eat or drink I don't know I
didn't think about that
let me see I don't know if she can hear
me I'll tell her but yeah that's
tomorrow so a little nervous wait yeah
they put you under for that right yeah
well yeah you can't eat
a long time before right well not like a
long time but can you check on that for
me do they put you under or isn't it
dangerous if there's stuff in your
stomach I don't know yeah I think you're
supposed to not it
at least eight dollars don't eat or
drink I'm gonna go to in and out before
yeah
just start projectile vomiting while I'm
asleep yeah yeah yeah
I'm saying not to eat or drink at least
eight hours before the procedure I
thought it's 12.
I'll play I'm gonna play it safe I'm
gonna do 12.
thank you
sure
um
but I saw some people saying they're
like kind of awake
dude this is what I see took guys please
somebody just wrote I woke up during a
colonoscopy endoscopy talk about human
centipede it was okay though don't see
let's keep that to yourself please don't
read anything please you woke up during
a double header
dude my friend did his colonoscopy with
no uh anesthetic
oh God what I've never heard of that
yeah neither have I did it why I don't
know you save money or something no no
he I guess the doctor said maybe they
didn't go deep enough up his ass but uh
he did it with no sedation is that a new
um is that a new game at a fist uh at
the fist Fest yeah fist Fest yeah that's
the doctor we need right there yeah all
right let's let's uh are we all ready I
guess we're waiting for Ian still I'm
back here where's Dan
I went to the bathroom
so we have basically the PowerPoint
we're going to talk about everything
since we last left off all aboard
um I hope you guys enjoyed Zach's song
Masterpiece oh and then actually oh are
we going too long or the or our callers
I've been I've been in communication
with them so actually we have also
um three uh members or three people who
are part of this story
um Johnny Becky and Oliver
are all calling in afterwards to discuss
so I'm actually pretty looking forward
to talking to them yeah Johnny was the
one who um
he was the one who was working for her
yes oh he's the one that posted the
Trisha pics right yeah that was she yeah
yeah and then uh Becky is the girl who
that were the uh on stage the split
situation okay okay and then Oliver is
the guy who
uh her brother was uh pursuing yeah
Oliver when he was 13. yeah yeah oh my
god
um yes Adam was unable to come today
sadly he had a pre-planned trip
um but we we did we do wish that he
could have been here obviously yeah I
hope he has the best time ever well he
said he's going to Disneyland with his
mom I was like yeah that's way better
stop he planned it like a year ago
apparently that's why I'm serious I'm
saying that's way better that is way
better that day it sounds so much more
fun
um all right well let's just get right
into it I guess all right
so let me open this up all aboard
part two baby oh I want to show you guys
no filter Jimmy
[Laughter]
awesome
it looks like a video game it does
all right guys now right off the bat I
do want to pose a question like
in a sense before the the All Aboard
song
it felt like she was her career was like
hopelessly kiboshed
but after the ukulele song
is there a chance for her to retain any
fans is she still on tour I certainly
hope not I know her Boise show was
canceled from it's yeah a show this week
was canceled was it the venue or was it
her I wonder
that I don't know I just know that it
was called off because she could play
that at the live show it'd be kind of
cool to play then oh you think she
should bust out the the tune on me right
give the people what they want right
it's true
all right here we go all aboard Colleen
Ballinger yikes part two
all right so before we begin these are
some affirmations from our girl Colleen
she said this um eight months ago
so I just think to put us on like a nice
moral track okay great this is after she
was she was listening to Karma by Taylor
Swift okay Swifty's in the house we love
swifties down because if you dare you'll
see the glare of everyone you burned
just to get there it's coming back
around so someone who is awful and makes
rumors and talks smack and is awful and
mean
um
everyone they've burned they're gonna
have to face someday because karma is
real in the sense that you know whether
you believe in woo-woo Karma like
there's some like
person or or God or universe or just
life or something make sure to go like
take note that person's not nice
if that or if you believe just like
that's true karma in a sense like if
you're a good person good you know good
things can happen and if you're a bad
person you know that's going to catch up
to you that's pretty deep stuff wow
she's so right about that uh she this
video is talking about my obsession with
Taylor Swift's new album for 40 minutes
straight I mean same girl
same girl
all right I'm a firmed I'm fully
Affirmed
so just some housekeeping that's a
pretty cool photo under a rock what's up
that's a cool photo that she took there
yeah
um yeah oh my God it's so over for Miss
Colleen
and Miss Miranda the both of them yeah
this isn't a Dr Jekyll Mr Hyde situation
they're both going down with the ship
yeah
okay so Shane Dawson who is famously
horrible literally warned us about
Colleen Ballinger Circa 2015. this is a
clip that resurfaced oh my gosh or
Colleen or Miranda all right depending
on how much where to do that Colleen is
the best because she needs 10 of these
fans she is the most hateful shadiest I
love her like whenever we hang out oh
wait you love her this [__] is the most
hateful Shady piece of [__] I've ever
known I love her I love her literally
the first words out of her mouth are
okay like what do you got who do you
hate who's next like just going in on
everybody holy crap you gotta get her
out here oh I would love to oh wait
Shane I don't think that
it sounds like you love her maybe bad
traits we're describing yeah that's not
like a nice way to describe your friend
I believe you certainly yeah she's
throwing a good word for us that's the
thing is a lot of you a lot of I guess
comedians in general like a lot of the
comedy comes from hate self-hatred when
you hate yourself you hate everybody
around yourself
I've got a little better at it but uh no
hanging out with her by the way I hate
that Trope this is [__] I hate when
people say stuff like that is that like
comedy comments comedy the only the way
it'd be funny is to hate yourself bro
and be miserable and sad all the time
that's where real comedy comes from like
the suffering artist
although to be fair all that stuff is
true about myself
no not really
man she loves to throw something pretty
much we get the gist we got it okay
Shane is really interesting yeah
interesting
so last time on H3
we just last time we were in studio we
talked about Colleen
um we talked about her inappropriate
relationships with fans we talked about
the group chats with young fans 13 to 17
years old we talked about her trauma
dumping on these young people about her
divorce and her relationship that they
publicly admired and watched for years
so they were already emotionally
invested
um she asked them sexual questions she
allegedly sent porn to them
um she schemed to take down a 17 year
old
um her family capitalized off of her
Fame to to fulfill their pedophilic
urges
um must I go on that's we've yeah we've
discussed in life we covered all that
stuff yeah yeah
also just a note here it I'm seeing
several of her upcoming live shows have
been canceled although the venues didn't
say whose decision it was if they all
haven't been canceled I'm assuming it's
the venues is she still trying to get
that paper you think yeah
for sure
okay humiliation I feel like of going on
stage can you imagine I mean she wasn't
Council before the ukulele song
yes the ukulele was like her hitting
that sort of that was like she was
already done so done yeah yeah but if
she doesn't care if she cares that
little why not go get paid
I don't know that she cares little the
amount wants to come spread eagle on the
stage
the only thing is like when I go on
Twitter or when I was going on Twitter
and it was like a buzz every single like
Colleen Ballinger news update Colleen
Ballinger fan page every single one of
them by the end had like denounced her
oh yeah yeah it was crazy like they're
they're accounts were still the profile
photos Colleen is like the bio I love
this woman with my whole heart with
their most recent tweet is
I guess this is it guys
I I thought that I knew who she was
that's kind of what happened to Kanye
when I think about it right Ian I mean
right yeah even the die hards had to
they're probably back with him though
right
what would no no not really oh so so I'm
with him
I feel like that we can really we can
talk about that
uh so Colleen and and uh Kanye have a
lot in common apparently yeah also
Colleen Hayes Jews as well no I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding
we'll talk about it does she have a does
she have one she had um a bit of an
anti-semitic tweet where she talked
about she was going in for an audition
I can't wait is it in here it's not but
I can pull it up yeah I mean if she's
anti-semitic I'd love to see it she's
just just normal Jewish question kind of
stuff yeah yeah it's not anti-semitic to
ask a question I mean the numbers
questions
what is math anti-semitic now
all right let's uh someone else oh you
got it God damn that was fast sorry I'm
perfect
so here it is uh 2011 edition number two
I'm going in for a fat ugly Jewish girl
I guess it's time for new head shots
I mean
it's not just the characters
on Kanye's level but yeah
okay so here we go what do we got here
okay okay okay so I made a little
timeline of
what
what like
fourth beginning of the month is when
all of these new allegations began to
rise
total radio silence for Miss Colleen she
did a few live shows even
she stopped vlogging she stopped posting
videos though June 21st that Wednesday
we covered Colleen Ballinger and the
story of Colleen Ballinger
yeah
then are you clearing up are you okay no
I just can't believe it like it was so
insane that we went on break and then
yeah right then yeah so we go on break
June 26th that Monday June 28th that
Wednesday Colleen comes out with the
most insane response I have ever seen on
the platform yeah it is I've ever seen
period it is by far by far I was like
this
it felt like a parody I couldn't even
believe it yeah jaw dropped like really
literally yes well something made me
think my first thought was like is she
okay
100 I was like this is like verging on
mental breakdown level of
divorce from reality right but the the
like dedication to choreo and like the
beats that she Incorporated it felt a
little bit too sane in terms of like she
knew exactly what she was doing well let
me ask you this do you think that she
thought
there was people in her audience or the
internet at large sure like this is
awesome she handled this so good so
here's what I think I think that first
of all she posted it on her Vlogs
Channel which means that that is
primarily where she posts mainly but it
has a smaller audience than her main
channels I think that she was banking on
the idea that maybe not everybody knows
exactly what it was that she did and so
maybe if she comes out and she's just
like there's a lot of lies about me blah
blah blah like maybe those people will
be like okay I love Colleen like I
believe her
Ian had this Banger tweet what is this
genre called love that's in here yeah
his uh what's that Thanksgiving mom
where he said he's gonna kill people or
something it's really weird where he
like continues to be the character from
the show kind of yeah it's like show's
over dude it got canceled because of you
actually didn't get canceled but all
right so
what did we miss over break besides
literally everything I put these are
screenshots of all of the articles that
dropped while we were on break okay this
is something not a lot of people talked
about go to the next one although I want
to read these oh all the grooming
allegations against Colleen that's the
independent BuzzFeed news uh Colleen is
facing serious backlash over her
insensitive and inappropriate song Oh
Brother she's a she's a children's
YouTube Star her fans say she groomed
them as teens brother brother brother
HuffPost those are not good headlines no
Los Angeles Times Colleen Ballinger
denies claims of grooming miners by
singing a song
okay BuzzFeed again all over this
variety uh the most reputable paper in
my opinion Colleen Ballinger creator of
YouTube Miranda Sings denies grooming
allegations and musical video that's a
very generous title
so 24 full hours before high
Colleen's response went up Corey De Soto
her best friend and assistant posted to
his Snapchat stories a black screen and
the the caption was the truth will set
you free dot dot dot so everyone's like
what
what is he talking about and then 24
hours uh All Aboard came out and I guess
that's what that's the truth
I assume so I assume that's what he was
talking about which is crazy Corey is
basically as he's in on all this stuff
using yeah he was like in group chat
yeah he was in the he had his own you're
saying that he already knew what she was
working on yeah yeah
he had his own group chat with minors
called uh the Corey's [__] Corey's clip
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um okay so he posted that on a Snapchat
story then 24 hours what Truth by the
way literally I don't know for a moment
time Stood Still for me a moment really
time Stood Still I lost my mind when I
saw this
um maybe let's just press play so by the
way 10 million views not bad girl that's
probably the most view she's gotten a
minute
girl is it monetized does she have ads I
hope so
I'm saying she got to make that
guacamole now
so um
let's okay so here we go this is the big
moment it says I do not condone or
support any kind of online bowling or
hate towards anyone ever
so I guess she thought maybe people were
gonna side with her and go ride
I think how could she I think I think
it's very delusional
I mean wait I don't know if you guys
want to watch it first but go ahead I
mean everyone's seen it because that
like the whole thing is she doesn't
acknowledge anything but talk about oh
you guys are gossiping me and therefore
my reputation is gonna die when it's no
your reputation is gonna die because of
what you did not because of people
gossiping about you
like shock about talk about the things
she ignores the serious points and
focuses on the gossip right so then
putting the blame on the gossip and
she's trying to appeal to people who
aren't familiar with everything to make
it seem like it's all gossip yeah
and literally like
we'll get to it we'll get to it so
anyway here it is uh and 1.4 million
dislikes
um 1.4 million is that an Alzheimer in
terms of like most disliked and it has
this is also with the likes and dislikes
being disabled right so it would have
been way or more I think potentially
yeah I think you're beginning to have
like the plug-in I don't have it for
example and I don't see that right
number one is still YouTube Rewind 2018.
rest in peace
but is she is she on the list like how
many dislikes does
some of those other videos have just
curious how sure YouTube Rewind is 19
million yeah that's I yeah uh we'll go
down to like number five you know what
Johnny Johnny yes papa
almost 12 million hate her ass hating on
poor little Johnny
all right so maybe not cracking the top
but it only has 10 million views you
know wow those shocked me
all right guys this is it this is my
as a virgin as I can do and the title
already high period is horrible
So Okay girl okay okay hi
all right
at this point at this point I was like
no yeah yeah yeah no not like the
funniest instrument too like a tiny
little guitar it's like a clown
instrument I somehow Ali caught this
and put it on
our TV in our living room when it was at
like 12 000 views it she had just posted
it shout out I got a notification
oh you had it still from years ago oh my
God by the way she is in no time I'm
sorry that was a mistake I'm sorry oh
okay it's retraction maybe she's in the
top ten and then he erased
it's a lot
all right so she pulls out this clown
instrument that's like the fun this
little time it looks like a drunken
little guitar it's very cute
oh my God nothing wrong with the ukulele
no it's just the funnest looking
instrument yeah I don't think she could
have picked the finer instrument to make
an apology with give me something
serious because you may be a kazoo it
would be pretty fun less serious what
about a violin something a violin is
better for the occasion I feel like this
is just so perfect because it's like a
good amount of funny and serious it's
insane like uh because it would be too
silly well I'm saying I'm I'm wondering
which instrument could be worse than a
ukulele I was thinking maybe a kazoo
maybe a triangle Cambo
[Music]
gossip
and she could talk over that we'd
forgive her okay
this is Phantom of the circus it would
be too much talent people would forgive
her for reals
all right here we go
I literally can't do that
the eyes I can't with the eyes
okay and even the beat is like
she's doing like kids content still this
is the most I have been doing a feeder
forever that's the most performance face
I've ever seen in my damn life and also
when I watched her show haters back off
there were some she has like a few
acting tells and you can literally see
them like in this she like her eyebrows
sometimes go down in her eyes like go
like this when she's acting and she does
it so often huh I don't think she's
hiding it though like what is it this is
clearly a performance but
she has to make it seem genuine why
would you do that I think she just means
it's just an acting tell like some
people say um a bunch or some people
like look to the side got it yeah and
may I also say the easiest chords you
can play g c and d oh and I have some
Insider tea about those chords that
progression yeah you're gonna save it
yeah it's in there it's in there okay
here we go it's been a while since I saw
my face not that long I haven't been
doing so great so I took a little break
a lot of people are saying some things
about me that aren't quite true it
doesn't matter if it's true though just
as long as it's entertaining so yeah
like oh my God so she's like as long as
it's entertaining she's not gonna say
what she's not gonna address which ones
are and aren't true yes she's just gonna
say
some of it's not true
and move on yeah what if I address this
in song I swear it's like a parody this
is like a spoof movie like naked gun or
some [__] when she started hitting the
Melody I couldn't deal
there's immediate
[Music]
thank you
your thing oh okay what that's awesome I
just buttoned
I buttoned out I buttoned out again I I
I don't know I said okay and then I
thought maybe I should have said it and
I looked at Dan and he wasn't laughing
you know what man that was fast you
think that I could have said that or not
I think you could have I have no idea
what it was I'm totally cool with you
pushing the button though
yeah
Dan what's your call
can I say the joke or should I keep it
underwrapped you already buttoned what's
the point I mean it wasn't really even a
joke
right maybe that's the problem all right
continuing on I got to get a piece of
cheese
yeah I hit the button Zach we're moving
on
how's that cheese by the way really good
you want one what flavor are you working
on I do want one yeah I'll get you it's
white cheddar okay throw me throw me
shetta
wait you're just not supposed to eat
for 12 hours already
but I can't eat dinner you can't eat
dinner I don't know where are we going
to order food today or no oh love is in
the house dude I'm so happy Love's here
what's our first order together what do
you want love [__] maybe some
Chick-fil-A Taco Bell that was awesome I
don't like you know what that sounds
perfect I'm gonna put my neck out I
don't like Chick-fil-A why I'm over it I
just don't think it's that good what
about ruining the bottom the chicken is
kind of just gamey and chewy and the
sandwiches are basic yeah that's crazy
though the sweet tea is so damn you a
cheese dealer boy
[Music]
you open the jacket don't take the
pepper jack
my cheese deal as well you need his
number text me
what time is my doctor appointment
tomorrow though so Taco Bell
I love Taco Bell I mean
it's at three I want oh you got a hot
blast so I don't know I'm so man we have
12 hours to eat oh okay it's 12 hours
okay not a whole day 12 hours yeah when
we got home yesterday from the airport I
ordered Taco Bell put in the order then
they told me it was closed oh
disappointed wow ubereats yes oh that's
[__] up I'm sorry that's brutal they
got this like fried chicken uh taco
right now fried what good fried chicken
there you go
got him yeah let's get TB in honor of uh
Miranda here's my dude oh yeah dude
he goes I hope you guys are having fun
and we're like yeah we're getting Taco
Bell where you can choose just as long
as it's entertaining it is I will never
I will never stop
all right we're gonna it's gonna take us
a long time
it's gonna take us a long time to get
through this video
all aboard the toxic box of train you're
chugging down the tracks of
misinformation and then her husband's in
the other room do you think he has
thoughts about this well you know what I
honestly know from watching their
content he is very into trains
oh he's a train enthusiast
s
you know too much girl
um so they wrote it together I'm almost
positive they like hum it around the
kitchen no
yeah they have to I think she's been
singing it at home for like two days for
real it's like they probably harmonize
with each other yeah it seems but do you
think her husband was like maybe not
because it seems like he's normalist
like he's not yeah he is
I mean I always thought he seemed pretty
normal but he's but if it's her career
then it's probably like well you know
Beth yeah right he's kind of following
her lead right I'm assuming because he's
not from YouTube right no he's a yeah
he's an actor he's like babe do you
think a ukulele apology is I mean I
don't know anything about YouTube okay
I'll follow your lead
I was thinking kazoo apology but
[Music]
who's she accusing of manipulating I
think the kids she's accusing the kid
she [__] with or like HuffPost who
like confirmed that the messages were
sent from her number I think that she's
saying that they're lying I think she's
talking like directly to Adam I feel
like I think so too it's nasty she the
idea that this little 14 year old kid
like just totally [__] destroyed her
that must eat her alive I sent him
panties how could he do this you mean
that's wild I didn't even think about
that that this is mostly addressed to us
oh yeah I think so
that makes sense I wasn't even thinking
about that yeah
it's like this is her fault facts if you
don't mind the gaps and survive
survived but hey
at least you're having fun
horrible
uh hi everyone I've been wanting to come
online and talk to you about a few
things
um even though my team has strongly
advised me to not say what I want to say
I recently realized that they never said
that I couldn't sing disgusting thing to
say got him she doesn't know my rules
always listen to Dan right listen to
your team girl listen to the team listen
to the team
don't do it don't do it she knows that
they meant don't sing also no she
thought it was cute hey actually if you
look hard enough the toxic gossip train
is actually been derailed this whole
time
[Music]
oh God Patricia said in her video that
she sent her a preview of The Toxic oh
yeah gossip drain and asked for her
opinion
train
to rain she has a great voice she really
is a beautiful singer it is impressive
10 minutes of this listen I'm gonna [__]
on her for all this I gotta I Gotta Give
she got a nice voice
from this like okay she's talented yeah
do you think she did a second take or
like another take because she thought
she didn't sound good oh she for sure
did many things yeah for sure it's like
she got all the words right but she was
like my voice sounds kind of bad yeah
but this is all one take two which
frankly is very impressive it's very
impressive
there's no cuts
no notes
I am and
um
I'm gonna talk about the fact
so
I hope that you'll be willing to listen
so my brother uh yes he was texting with
a 14 year old and uh trying to meet up
with him and uh
um yes I did send porn oh she's not
gonna say any of that yes I did said
porn to minors
[Music]
fans uh but not in a creepy way like a
lot of you are trying to suggest it was
more of a loser kind of way I was just
training me which is your opinion the
problem is her she thinks her perception
is the Ultimate Reality so she's not
willing to hear them talk about how it
affected them she knows she goes at the
time
I was I didn't think it was creepy in my
attention I didn't I wasn't being creepy
but then everyone's being like no I
thought I felt in retrospect now as an
adult that it's creepy and she's
refusing yes she's showing no
growth no as a person like she's stuck
thinking that was just oh I'm just a
loser zero no you're a grown-up now
you're a mother yourself you need to
look at the situation and acknowledge
what happened is not okay you were an
adult talking to children that was not
appropriate you should you just need to
acknowledge you need to show some growth
like she's just like I was a loser I
mean it was silly I've been there when
the whole tournament internet like dog
piles and it's at first my responses
back in the day when I had a less
healthy relation of maybe less mature I
don't know was always to get very
defensive that's the natural way because
you don't want to admit that
you did something bad or that you were
wrong it's hard to it's really hard to
come to terms with that kind of thing
because maybe you didn't think you were
doing something wrong at that time
that's where the problem comes from
because and of course people don't go
out purposely to do
um
to do something bad you know what I mean
yeah
R Kelly's like
nah even R Kelly knows he [__] up
[Applause]
everybody
it's kind of like uh when you go to like
a family gathering and there's a weird
ant there keeps coming up to you and
going like hey girl what's the team
you're like no it's more like everybody
yeah it's worse than hey girl what's the
T but she actually does have her brother
is the molesting uncle
you know that joke everybody got that
molesting Uncle well she Miranda Sings a
huge part of her character is the like
Daddy saddle is what it's called it's
what her she would put on her uncle so
she could ride him around the house like
all of a lot of her jokes were
incest
insinuation I noticed that yeah yeah
it's I can't believe I didn't pick up on
it
I mean to be fair I didn't really well
aboard the incest train
the
magical incest train yeah I'm hopping on
my uncle's lap he's got a boner let's go
[Music]
it was weird
I've been sharing my life online for
over 15 years yeah I just think you're
glossing over something that's more
serious
God she was possessing that frame
holy [__]
for my heart out
[Music]
come to my friends but in the beginning
of my career I didn't really understand
that maybe there should be some
boundaries there there were times that
[Music]
weird of me I haven't done that well
unpack that what was weird about it you
know what I mean what is it you shared
what was weird about it you're not
digging deep enough girl
yep she's minimizing it it wasn't just
weird it was inappropriate you know this
is like
a little bit more serious
[Music]
foreign
do you like the supreme or the bean
cheese rice one oh yeah yeah
anyway Colleen uh yeah anyway uh yeah
yes yeah so
um do you want to keep watching it I
mean we yes
do you want to put it in 1.25
what's the hurry we do have um people
calling in oh do I just don't wanna that
is a good point maybe we should talk to
them do you want to make because I don't
want to keep them waiting forever we can
talk to them first we went over their
stories
I don't want to make them rude lead away
because I do
I do want to um
also take my time on this they're
thinking it's my button
none of them have a heart out they don't
mind waiting like an hour because if
they if it's a problem we can do the
call now the last thing they said was
you're okay I don't think any of us have
a heart out and do you have your own
weenies chat there with them
you can you guys can hush it's in
Twitter and it's sweet and we're all I
think you all are the same age now we
are the same yeah pretty much but um
yeah no it seems like it'll it's okay
okay good okay cool that's great
sorry guys to make your way I'm more
than happy to put you on now but okay
so let's go on the toxic
ity
though the locomotives fueled with
hateful accusations
[Music]
reputation
toxic gossip
on board but close your eyes otherwise
you'll realize that the train is made of
lies and that person you despise maybe
didn't deserve to die but hey
at least you're having fun what about
the kids who are getting death threats
from your fans God that part was so
crazy I mean it's like [__] it's hard to
Fathom it's hard it's really hard it's
hard to Fathom I I constantly wonder
what was her objective with this
I I really think she is so deep in like
feeling like such a victim and she's
thinking I'm gonna show them
that they're doing me wrong people are
gonna sympathize with me I'm right
you're wrong yeah and I'm gonna prove it
via song
like everybody on the Internet is
against me right now you know what
no one has sang like she has sung and
that's the difference
Jesus and it's it's just so transparent
too the way she minimizing everything
yeah she's like I was just insecure but
anyway that's not that fun of an
explanation it's like well girl
what about the freaking porn and putting
tampons in their mouth and [__] like I
mean
you're 30.
weird it's worse than weird mm-hmm
really weird
in all seriousness I do think it's
really important to hold people
accountable for their mistakes okay
um right you know we should hope that
everyone with that being said I've done
nothing wrong
I only [__] nothing and I would hold
myself accountable if I did anything
wrong [__]
that's awesome
Dude Love's got crazy order it loves
ordering Taco Bell [__] than I never
heard of and you just got here he goes
creamy Chipotle crispy chicken taco like
what try one try one and then Cam's got
some good the potato equivalent of that
one and uh it's quite good so wait and
then cam ordered a spicy potato taco
that sounds can I get it
that's like the potato equivalent of
What Love Got okay so I wanna I also
want a spicy potato taco and a creamy
creamy Chipotle crispy chicken ukulele
apology Taco me too make it two of those
with extra sass
learn from their mistakes and grow and
change their behavior and
we tried to do it when I make this it's
something that I will continue to try to
do what oh you don't care oh okay see
like that
hold on hold on we do with me that's in
like intensely rehearsed I don't say we
don't care why'd you cut yourself off
that's the only thing we care about we
actually want to we actually do care
she knows she knows
so annoying oh what you don't care it's
like you haven't even talked about it
though what how do you know we don't
care what people obviously do care
that's why they're mad at you
right Olivia you care I actually I
really do care yeah I was really even
extremely upset about all of this
it's true
this is so dude come on it's just mean
it's like just mean to your fans who you
know what I mean I'm so embarrassed like
people when this came out I was already
embarrassed oh my God I can't believe I
devoted so much of my time to this woman
I gave her so much of my time and then
she had the judgment to go and post
something like that oh my God what did I
learn subliminally from her don't worry
it was don't worry it doesn't it doesn't
take away from the the good memories
yeah hope so you know what I mean can I
just uh call attention to something I I
was curious if people had transcribed
all the lyrics and not only did they
transcribe it but do you know on that
website genius yeah and how people can
put connotations
oh
look on through and annotated every line
of it and why she's rolling this [__]
why wow that's amazing more like fact
checking her images
and this is more uh annotations than a
doctor a PhD yeah
dissertation this is so funny oh it
smokes that's got more uh Corrections
than uh Ryan Kavanaugh's Wikipedia page
right got him
shout out Ryan by the way scumbag oh
nice dude wait did we talk about Ryan's
new tea about him being uh threatened to
be sued by
no we didn't because we went on break
there's really good cabinet
that's too much
we got it so so okay I'm not gonna get
it yeah but Wednesday I put a note we
gotta we got it better be yeah it's good
good calf Cafe
yeah
and be a better person this is something
that I've always tried to do when I make
mistakes and it's something that I went
back because I couldn't believe this oh
you don't care oh
nobody said that
that's the one thing we want to hear go
on it's so mean
it's like oh you're a stupid piece of
[__] right
you're the one being disingenuous we I
was listening
I could take this opportunity to
actually try to explain my behavior but
oh you don't care
[Music]
is it no your goal is to ruin the life
of the person you despise while you
dramatize your lies and monetize their
Divine you know it's weird something I
learned about while I was being on the
internet yeah and I've been on the
receiving end of a lot of
I'm not going to say hey but a lot of
criticism some hate and some criticism
and you know when you're at first when
you get defensive it feels like they
just are trying to ruin you and they
hate you and all this but
it's really not true ultimately some
people do but not the majority I think
when you
are able to like look authentically and
genuinely from outside yourself and to
just fully accept the criticism just
fully take it on
people are people actually like to see
that it's really hard to do but it's
actually
the people they don't want to destroy
you they want to see that they want to
see you taking accountability and then
the people are actually surprisingly
forgiving when they see
that there is a recognition of a mistake
yeah because nobody is actually looking
for a bad outcome you know of anything
here but not most you know I mean not
most sure there's always going to be
something but like
I would have much preferred to see her
openly talk about it and say I don't
know like be vulnerable yes also Adam
from
like the day it began like June 4th or
whenever Cody uploaded that video Adam
was always saying Colleen Ballinger if
you contact me privately and you and you
apologize and then you publicly
apologize to me I will never speak about
this again he that's what he said the
whole time and she refuses to even maybe
have a conversation with someone whose
life she altered so greatly like it's
just
um it's absolutely thoughtless it's
unfortunate that she's just so like yeah
defensive about everything yeah really
sad
yes
I feel like I can already hear the
comments on this video she's gaslighting
manipulating us she's a narcissist
interact I would never make a mistake
like that oh no I haven't sent porn to
children so that's fair yeah she
was in like Cinderella or something I
would never
I gotta say her her strumming a rhythm
not terrible she's good no she's not she
sounded she's talented yeah
we're giving her a lot of credit you
guys
it's fine no I want to be partial to the
fact that listen as a musician she's
very talented
yeah as an Entertainer I can see why she
was successful you know that shows that
there is talent and skill right but she
is just going like people this is a
broken person entertaining I think
there's probably better singers and um
she's not the best singer in the world
no no yeah right
for this type of video Rhythm not bad
we're not we're not wanting to give her
any credit
that's I think where I am right now yeah
yeah
which is beautiful I love that couch
great pillows yeah pillow decoration is
great what's up here TJ Maxx you know
maybe some Home Goods what is this a
little sketch that's cool yeah it's good
she's a wonderful homemaker
wonderfulness
that's wonderful that all of you are
perfect so please criticize me bring out
the daggers made from your perfect past
and stab me repeatedly in my bony little
back I'm sure phony okay I have the next
slide I put so one of the things that
these kids were accusing her of was
um body checking constantly and
like consistently telling them that like
skinny was good like she would tell Adam
like oh Adam you look skinny like when
he was a kid and so I think that that is
a direct response of her being like [__]
you I'm skinny whatever which is an
insane thing so what does body checking
mean body checking in her videos like
she'll go she'll look into the camera
and then she'll go side to side and it's
called body oh she actually does that a
lot of people do it like through habit
but it's some it's something that has
become like a problem in her in her yeah
I mean the problems have since gotten
much greater but she is very um
I mean yeah she's very she's very uh
put this delicately and stab me
repeatedly in my bony
I want to put this delicately and as
delicate as her tiny body is
[Music]
little back it's so nasty
in my bony little back crazy in my
shitty little
song
[Music]
you dummy you stupid idiot dummy
I know you all want me to apologize but
[__] you but at the time same time she's
like I think people need to take
accountability oh what you don't care
about that
girl just listen to yourself the answer
is in your song yeah you are wrong in
some cases you are wrong in some things
in the wrong well I'm sorry I'm not
I'm not how's that working for you
for you crazy so that's that says you
want her to be more specific what rumors
were made up for cloud
right because we know that some of them
are actually proven to be true oh yeah
so what's real it's not according to
clean I need her to be more specific if
there's rumors made up for clout let's
spell it out sis yeah
that's body check the the facts for
reals
thank you
[Music]
but I do not like in her past so
everybody gather round cause we're about
to attack but not based on facts Oh no
you're loaded Lethal Weapon is your
fingers on the case you don't need any
armor when you can hide behind a screen
so Shoot Me Down
lin-manuel would hate this presentations
to see that's all I know what lin-manuel
would hate this you think so yeah that'd
be the ultimate he needs to denounce we
need his commentary
I mean yeah as you've been on the
internet long enough to know that yeah
people get mad at you when [__] happens
I mean you know big surprise I also
wanted to take a minute to talk about
that girl Miranda Sings you know the one
I got her she's PG-13 okay okay as soon
as I saw this when I watched this for
the first time yeah I said okay it's
PG-13 I went to her shows they are all
ages every single one of her shows is
all ages she added um I have it on a
slide a few slides down she added a
disclaimer a few years ago
like this it was for kids oh she added
it a few years ago
oh or not interesting but it is all ages
I mean if you want if you don't want
kids to just make it 13 plus
like our show is 18 plus because we
showed a man fully prolapsing right
so true cheers my dude cheers my dude
it says that on my website and it's
always been that way and that's why you
won't find my videos on the YouTube kids
app anyway okay well that's a whole
different okay we're not talking about
three-year-old the YouTube kids app
stuff is like for babies yeah
but then so so this claim is so silly
because she has people under 13
participating in the show right right so
it's like what are you talking about in
like her shows today she still does
Miranda thanks yeah that's the whole
show yeah okay so the the way her her
shows work is she comes out as Colleen
okay and then she sings a few songs as
herself and then usually she would do a
song like Defying Gravity or she changed
it to like Let It Go from Frozen for a
minute and she made song Transitions and
like changes into Miranda Sings and then
like puts on her lipstick and then Sings
Miranda for the rest of the show
um
does Disney know she's doing that I
don't know bro we should tell them you
know what I'm saying
I'm just saying I don't think they want
that Association
Disney if you're watching
yeah it's it's such a stupid plan and
that and it's off like you see you can't
just sing about it and move on your
nonsense you just said nothing basically
because you're saying it's All PG-13 and
it's not you have the shows right now
all ages and they're all ages so don't
be silly and you call them to
participate stop it
I didn't realize it was my
responsibility you need to decide what
was appropriate for every kid to see
also like that's true that's Parts true
it's not her she doesn't control what's
appropriate for kids to watch parents
need to do that if they don't if they
don't think it's appropriate she's true
about that but this whole thing of I'm
not making content for children like
when she goes to meet and greets and she
does her shows she sees the people that
are there year after year after year
they're they're kids
you know kids loved Hitler okay well
this might this might be interesting
um apparently lin-manuel uh Co ghost
wrote this song
oh my God no wonder it's so fire yeah
yeah yeah no wonder it's got that beat
yeah
I've always relied on parents to decide
if they're comfortable with their
families watching my YouTube videos or
coming to
shows
is he thirst trapping what is this photo
this is one of my faves this is my
favorite photo ever why is he thirst
crapping me there's a bunch dude there's
like a lot I don't like it this is his
move no I want to see more
he does that I gotta find the fan cam
wait why is he why is he doing that stop
it I'm not kidding that's the latest
thing that's his thing
wait stop look at that haircut jacket
he can do whatever he wants he's such a
talent he can bite I mean except for
ghost right for Colleen oh here's a
whole Pinterest page of just him biting
you know Hitman Miranda Sings actually
did do a video together
um did they yeah a long time ago
so people find it cringy because this
says his cringy blip biting
I love him he is so talented
I agree
are they saying yeah they sang a song
from um
Spring Awakening together in 13 years
ago it was on Earth May 20th 2010. yes
she she was like the biggest deal uh for
a minute
well this is copyrighted but here's a
slide I guess unrelated why are you
doing that wait what wait what why are
you doing this so we're in the chat just
called him theater Drake oh my God oh my
God that's so good I won't deny that
literally so talented so cringe I hate
him so much okay I love him forever
listen the one that's really throwing me
off is like this one like
because it's like you're not even doing
you're just doing why are you doing that
man
all right moving on let's not get juice
[Music]
stop ruining everything no I still love
them
okay sound up please Zach
my YouTube videos or
[Music]
girls or crab I made some jokes and poor
taste yes I haven't made lots of dumbs
this is not edited
he definitely ghost wrote this this is a
real photo stop
he was probably he was planned in the
seeds even back then he's such a genius
he was like toxic
exactly
right I'm getting too distracted here
I'm in too much fun sorry Colleen we're
having too much fun and Defiance at
least you're having fun we are all right
girl
have I made some jokes and four taste
yes yup I haven't made lots
[Music]
but I say so this is an important part
because again she keeps going back to
her intentions her intentions don't
matter and we know that right even back
in the is the [__] all the way back
the Bible says good is it the Bible the
Bible the path to hell is paved with
good intentions I don't think that's in
the Bible it's not I thought that was a
Biblical thing yeah
but intentions don't equal
outcome yes outcome and so sometimes I
think I gotta find the origin of this uh
it was in a newspaper in 1828 uh people
do not know the exact origin
um it's a great quote Yeah it's a
proverb yeah it's a great quote because
like I think most people in everything
they do have good intentions you could
say Hitler had good intentions you know
what I mean they use an extreme example
[Laughter]
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions yeah
yeah
okay this is too far you guys oh my this
is all right Cameron that's [__] up oh
my God you guys all right
you see I said he got it
it's good intentions
damn dude
shame on you shame on you
I'm sorry not the greatest thing you've
ever made
I did find this tweet too no she did not
tweet that
anyone else read this book the protocols
of the Elders of Zion kind of no that's
made up
I may have made it oh my God you got me
you never know with her man this is
crazy dude
Cameron Dan and I were waiting we were
goofing we were goofing on the side this
whole time oh my God you guys are
sitting on those huh
but yeah this this part is important let
me let me go back here
or taste yes I haven't made lots of dumb
mistakes yes yes am I sad that there are
some fans who feel betrayed yes no no
this is my intention to manipulate yep
no
it doesn't really matter yeah so again
like the intentions don't matter it's
the outcome you say you're because I
think you're operating it could be she's
operating fully subconsciously uh when
she's doing these things it's possible
I'm not saying it's what happened but
again that's part of the Reckoning of
coming to terms with the things you've
done it's not about your attentions it's
about the outcome
and the I mean the people that came out
with their experience they were kids
then they're now adults adults right and
they're telling you how they feel and
felt and like where where is the
conversation about that I just don't
understand so you could say oh they're
doing it for clout but so some of them
are creators but a lot of them are they
have nothing to gain from this right
Olivia right yeah so it's not you can't
just sweep it all under the rug like oh
they're clout Chasers yeah Becky only
came out and told her story because
someone else was telling it for her
right right right right yeah
my intention was because it seems as
though everyone's already decided on
that
let me tell you it's not very fun to
have millions of people all over the
world call you the most Curly it's not
that fun to be like a 14 year old girl
and do the spread eagle thing on stage
like that girl she's talked about it as
an adult now or um as you know I don't
know how old she is now but maybe her
20s or something about that was a that
was a very bad experience for her so
like girl grow up
vile
vile horrendous
disgusting life ruining words that a
person can be called in my opinion
um
are you sure about the ukulele right now
literally are we sure this is the right
move girl
you know you're playing a ukulele right
[Music]
who manipulates and abuses children
tell me how you're not yeah I mean
there's that's pretty well supported
now abused as in like are you essaying
them like there's obviously a spectrum
right I don't know if she's like oh well
abuse is only when like uh
there's essay or something but like
um it's well it's very well supported by
many people now that you were
manipulating and abusing in a sense
right children like so again
just a lot of denial here
I just wanted to say that
um I've ever groomed is my two Persian
cats that is so disrespectful to every
kid who came out and told their story
that's a that's unhinged line what
though who will let that go
she must have thought like oh is that
one a little bit crazy
entertaining the only thing I've groomed
is
[Music]
she was like yes those are so smart
crazy
that is so unhinged I think that line
came to her in a dream or something yeah
in the shower the best ideas come to you
I think mint Lin Manuel you think that's
Lynn yeah
it's too genius you're good
I'm not a groomer I'm just a loser
horrible life
you can be both I mean you're right you
actually usually the overlap happens
yeah yeah you know it's funny that's
what James Charles also said about
himself you're right he said I'm
desperate I'm just desperate I'm
desperate that worked for him for some
reason I don't know why James Charles
isn't getting the Miranda Sings because
he didn't make a ukulele video yeah but
he literally all like he literally made
a video saying I'm just lonely that's
why I'm flirting with yeah on a ukulele
it probably would have blown up in his
face even more like this was the
stupidest like crazy we talked about
this on the show but I wasn't really
aware of any of it because in my world
it doesn't make sense why he's not
getting a bigger taking this reactions I
agree something doesn't make sense with
that whole thing because it this is such
a spectacle I mean this went Way Beyond
the borders of like right not just her
fan base but even the people that
normally would criticize her this is
YouTube Hall of Fame yeah this became
this is going this was like the normies
we're all aware of this you know
this is like death to Jews wouldn't you
say they are also all aware of James
allegations I feel like that's kind of
like mainstream knowledge it didn't hit
all the like news
sources like Colleen Did definitely not
I've never asked a child to show me
their armpit hair I'm like well that's
true I've never tried to
um fly a child out to have sex with me
well okay she has a point
if she just compared herself to James
right she's the James verse allegedly by
the way that's flying the kid out thing
I allegedly I think that happened but
I'm not sure I don't want to be suited
for defamation anymore right
please
we have a lot to get through all aboard
can I see your armpit hair
send me a picture of you in the shower
with your armpits up
Miranda had Time Magazine and rolling
stone write articles about it so
Affiliates completely different level
yeah huff post and he did not LA Times
yeah they don't [__] write about
gossip James no I don't think so really
no that's crazy it's the uke man you're
right Dan she yuked it up
she yuked herself dude
[Music]
what horrible five years ago you made a
fart joke so insanely disrespectful how
are you gonna how are you gonna actually
reduce it to that nobody I didn't even
say anything about a fart joke yeah what
are we even talking about that's what uh
that's the Becky story
girl what is wrong with you yeah wow are
you serious you brought a young girl on
stage you exploited her body and you
called it a fart joke she didn't
complain about the farm joke I don't
think that's what bothered her yeah yeah
I'm pretty sure that's not what bothered
her did
wow that was awesome
[Music]
horrible I gotta go back again I think
so because five years ago I made a bark
joke that's so [__] up I'm laughing
because it's so [__] up it's nasty
this girl actually came out and talked
about it as a like a grown-up and you're
like man it's just a fart joke grow up
insane
holy [__] that's super unhinged
people are saying the age Gap being so
much bigger would hurt than with Charles
because he's much younger she was 30
when all this was happening yeah yeah
you're right James was like 22. I don't
know how James is pretty young maybe
even younger to be maybe even younger
like 20 or 21. not that it wasn't bad
but yeah it definitely escalated into
quite a bit between 30. yeah you've got
to your brain is solidified it's fully
developed yeah you can't you can't
really you're doing this James was 21 in
20 21. [__] you [__] you dude James
Charles is older than me and he I don't
know I think that I like I'm not
defending yeah I know but I think you
know just to the point of why did this
get so much more attention I think the
age Gap does have something to do with
it yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah well actually yeah and the
send she sent uh
yeah yeah
fart joke okay yeah I like to minimize
some of the things that I've got in
trouble for it's like uh I probably
shouldn't no names yeah don't do that
but it could be fun to uh play that game
for myself
it's like James Charles all I did was
trying to find friends on the internet
not as not good enough all I was doing
is trying to let's see Epstein being
like all I was trying to do was give
children a game uh employment yeah
Matchmaker yeah you made a history you
play a Matchmaker you made a history
joke about Ben Shapiro all I did was
make a history joke well that one I'm
not apologetic I still don't apologize
for that one I'm I'm fully Miranda Sings
on that bench
give me the ukulele I'm never walking
that one though
oh
anywhere what was I
fart joke yeah she the fart joke line
put her
she's almost in tears because the fart
joke is Injustice
[Laughter]
won't change anyone's mind about me
that's true
I still felt it was important to come on
here
and defend myself little
girl please she didn't she did it
she just sang a little bit yes she
didn't really put up any meaningfulness
no defense no offense spark joke all I
did was tell a fart joke
[Music]
that's horrible
and I also wanted to say that to anyone
out there who has ever supported me in
any capacity you Olivia I know if she's
talking to you I appreciate you
thank you your thoughts on that yeah
you're welcome right that's aim toward
you
fart joke fart joke
no thoughts all I gotta say s sucks yeah
and many more
there's three minutes left still
at the eight minute mark
a lot of there's a lot of speculation as
to what exactly she was doing you'll see
oh okay interesting
what is happening
[Music]
your time
rumors look like facts when you don't
mind the gaps
I won't survive in the crash but hey
I hope yeah it's some fun
yeah it's a pretty good time
I mean it wasn't I understand it's
pretty serious but I did have fun
talking about it at times
without downplaying the seriousness of
it I'm just responding to her
she did do some pretty insane things for
us I gotta say consume sometimes for me
I just love when I'm not the one
catching the [__]
I'm just happy it ain't me that's how
anybody feels on YouTube I feel like
whenever there's a drama they're not so
much times man and I know how bad it
sucks so in that sense I empathize with
her but also it's like she deserves this
yeah
you [__] this up pretty bad girl
some people think that she was checking
to see if um she had gotten to 10
minutes yet yeah
hold on hold on hold on hold on because
this is so rehearsed people are like is
that her pretending to be like you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna riff a little bit
yeah that's what I thought the 10
minutes thing is because the videos
don't have to be 10 minutes yeah that's
been irrelevant okay
um
really she might no she's dude she's
been posting Vlogs for since like weekly
she knows about it maybe
um
well then this is extra extra script
okay so I haven't seen this part
so she made it look like she turned off
the camera but then like she was going
to because
just one more thing I'm sure whatever
she's doing is superscripted I mean it
all is
so let's see
so I think she meant like oh wait not
yet I have a little bit more to say yes
I feel like maybe I should you guys know
something
um it seems like more Uke oh yeah you
could put the uke down
this is her chestnuts yeah
we have that in common yeah
if you're confused about something I
don't know
let me try to help
um
what's happening sometimes people make a
mistake and it does and make them a
horrible person whoa what was the
mistake and
they're still a good person crazy I know
sometimes I mean nobody's oh my God
nobody's saying someone auditioned with
that line read I would say nope I mean
this is painful this is something that
she needs to talk to herself and her
therapist about
like yes right that's a conversation for
you to have with yourself when your
husband maybe you can make mistakes and
still yeah yeah yeah that's well that's
between you and God yes I don't care
about that but
um
she's a far way off of I feel like
emotionally evolving yeah because it
takes
the um the Rhythm change here it's
almost like when Kendrick changes the
right like a beetle
yeah it's awesome Dynamic man I love the
stuff
[Music]
and twist it up and grind it and add
some lies to it and it pulls the Horizon
stab it with knives
[Music]
you seem upset
it doesn't mean you gotta send them
no sometimes people can make a mistake
and you can kindly let them know and
help them to grow hey girl just wanted
to let you know like you you groomed a
few kids in the process of your career
just wanted to let you know well so bye
for example the girl who um
the girl who she opened her legs on
stage it wasn't like cruel or mean she
that's kind of what she did she's like
listen it was it was traumatic for me
this happened and then her response to
that was
um fart joke fart joke insane
what happened to the audio
mistakes
simply because
they made a mistake
doesn't make them a terrible human
well it depends on the mistake frankly I
agree that's you know what I mean right
mistake is a broad that's all broad
spectrum of actions I agree yeah [__] me
right oh girl you didn't stop I gotta go
back
[Music]
oh
I'm a human
what do I know
[__] me right yeah you know her her
friend uh
what's his name who lives with her Corey
so he's behind the camera he's like
perfect yeah
nailed it do you think that
[__] me was scripted or do you think
that was her scripted yeah oh you do
definitely not me right that whole thing
is the whole especially that the way she
changed the bit at the end it was like
so rehearsed
yeah yes yes yes
um yeah I mean that's YouTube Hall of
Fame I can't believe she did 10 minute
20 second ukulele apology I mean yeah I
I it's impressive frankly and I
applauded the novelty of it I mean she
is trailblazing in a sense
famously horrible
yeah notorious notorious joke fart joke
I'm gonna have to ask uh Becky about the
yeah I was reading some of her tweets
she was really really upset about you
didn't like that of course not can you
imagine
yeah why are you offended about fart
jokes
ridiculous
wow okay well there it is yeah I mean
it's it's
like it would be EDP making a song all I
wanted was a cupcake and you guys are
making rumors and gossip about me
yeah that's true
all right so I guess we're moving on yes
time Stood Still yeah it's true
yeah maybe refresh it because I moved
two slides okay
refresh there we all thank you
absolutely
go ahead okay so we talked about this
bony little back
that part was crazy we don't have to
watch it Ellen Ballinger when she added
my bony little back to her song yeah
she's like I'm so skinny you think she
was that was a brag 100 million percent
what I wasn't sure because I don't know
I haven't watched her stuff so I don't
know what you're talking about it was at
the very least a dig because there was a
lot of discourse about like choline
perpetuates possibly eating disorder
culture in her Vlogs oh I saw that
that's a big topic of combo and I think
that that was her being like [__] you
I'm skinny I saw it as a
self-deprecating but I don't have all
the context right
okay
that's crazy if that's like a compliment
to herself okay this is Insider tea and
I think you're really gonna like this so
the chord progression
it's interesting it reminded some of us
Colleen fans of
something do you remember when I told
you that Colleen went to Canada to film
the first season of her show and she
came back to visit one time her husband
and this is possibly when she well this
is when she met and started becoming
friends with who is now her husband and
father of her children
um she came home one time for their
anniversary they barely vlogged the Vlog
was so [__] weird you could tell that
something was wrong and Colleen in this
Vlog wrote a very uncomfortable song for
Josh with the same chord progression the
exact same chord regression and it's
called Joshua's blue eyes and it's the
least personal song ever because they
were clearly breaking up I love this you
gotta appreciate like her dedications
like I'm in the midst of a divorce and
I'm putting out this goddamn vlog
wow so this is her ex yeah
on your wrist before look at how
miserable they've seen about you every
day ew I hate freckles and there's like
a little tiny chocolate chip I
get Josh a present so I'm writing him a
song this is a song did she do the
equivalent of like when dudes become
like rich and famous they like leave
their normal wife for like I don't know
I I know that like they were they were
weird together for sure so I don't know
but because her new husband's like an
actor honk extraordinaire right hunk
yeah okay I don't know yeah I mean like
he's he's good looking maybe I should
look at it yeah let's see I don't
actually know talented he did a good job
hunk of a man Miranda Sings husband
steaming hunk pile of a man Eric
stocklin is his name yeah I mean he
okay I mean
yeah
I guess he's not super hunky like but
kind of a dobrik face in it
you see that mm-hmm
[Music]
hi David
all right anyway I love I can't wait for
this it's amazing
I liked it for the last 20 minutes
oh
wait has she been singing it to him well
she's been writing it
and the cut also after she's like
wait wait wait wait
she wrote this for him in front of him
yeah she was practicing it I think she's
supposed to if it's like a present or
something well she said she didn't get
him a gift so she's been writing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh wow that hurts at this point he's
already gotten himself like a dog
oh my goodness
named Shadow this guy's dying inside
yeah
let's check the time yeah
oh [__]
yeah he's so over it so upset because
it's like she's making it all about her
being like this great performer right on
his like his yeah and putting it on
display she's saying nothing about him
she's just like you have blue blue eyes
it's really just about her singing yeah
yeah
oh a ukulele too is this so this is it's
the same chord progression it sounds the
same oh so she's been she's been
marinating on this one for a minute
she's been dealing with this tune this
tune is traumatic for her and get it out
of her head
toxic Joshua train
yeah it's exactly the same
[Music]
incredible
this is really
this is really really good
[Music]
he said in their video so this was like
July
um September is when they announced the
divorce in Josh's video he says I didn't
want this wow yeah there's no way he
already knew and would sit there he had
at least a suspicion yeah that I that I
believe okay
something is wet here I don't know there
was this was wet I don't know what it's
in it or what it's just water I think
though
yeah wet ass people just some wet ass
pee word thank you Zach
this is incredible I mean this is really
something crazy
oh God
he's so what the [__] this is brutal
this is almost as bad as the goddamn the
Johnson train yeah
like watching him crumble yeah
oh my God the smile she gives
[Music]
oh my God
oh that's a good joke
her blue uh her brown eyes look like
poop yeah
[Music]
you were saying that the Vlog was weird
I see why the what the the this is this
is the video oh yeah this Vlog was in
that was pretty much all of it they they
were like laying on the couch not
looking at each other talking about how
much they didn't do that day and then
she's like we didn't really Vlog at all
today here's a song that was it
I mean you can't get a better place like
are you serious right now
I don't know if like the majority of the
fan base picked up on it but I
definitely know that I posted like I
remember posting on my finsta a photo of
them and I was like I'm pretty positive
these two are getting a divorce and then
the next week they announced it wow oh
wow you're in tune watch his reaction
right here
why are you doing this yeah
[__] why
why are you playing this video I think
it's a safe face because she had posted
on Twitter like people were speculating
that they were getting a divorce when
she was in Canada because she wasn't uh
visiting and so she posted a bunch of
photos of them kissing on Twitter and
was like yeah we're getting a divorce so
I think she was just saving face and
she's like I'm gonna go home because I
have to film a [__] Vlog but look at
him there ain't no face to save this
man's not done yeah
look at him he's talking to the audience
yeah he's like you see what I have to
[__] put up with right now
he's like UAB okay this this is this is
hard to this is the worst thing ever I
got this is brutal I gotta get out of
here get out of here I gotta get off
this agree holy [__]
and Josh is like fully openly against
her now right like he is he
I mean you will you'll talk to Johnny
Johnny had his own relationship with
Joshua
right I heard that I found that a little
odd too
um here it is
next
all right in-house reception to toxic
gossip train Ethan posted on his story
uh when we come back from break so I can
do it with the girlies thank you so much
thank you so much
um you also put a poll up that said
Ethan Klein video now when podcast comes
back and you still didn't do it which is
so nice I was so close to breaking and I
was like ah I was so grateful then I I
said no no and I'm going on break this
is like a break I'm not working right
all aboard all aboard
okay all right in-house reception Ian
posted that thing what is this genre
called I said I'd say dark comedy
elements of surrealism and I cannot
believe this is happening is um Sam said
toxic gossip
Zach said nothing like an apology video
while strumming a G chord and cam made a
little meme that says toxic gossip train
now available on Steam player what oh
that's Kanye in and uh yeah
Charles Manson
whatever his name is
so who said this couldn't be a duet this
is Adam's response he sang there's like
a tiny little clip in this uh the watch
yeah
they do it he put together yeah oh
that's good
[Music]
accusations
like he did to a 17 year old
let's not forget that
yeah for real
wow um this is a tweet I loved Miranda
Sings apologizing for five counts of
battery two counts of vehicular
manslaughter and domestic terrorism
and that's Millie Bobby Brown singing
imagine oh poor belly here yeah yeah
Millie she's still catching heat I love
Millie I love Millie the mean and I love
Millie the girl what was that Meme back
in the day that she was like a raging
homophone yes that she was just for no
reason oh my God I forgot about that I
hate to say it was pretty cool but it
was so funny yeah it was really funny oh
my God all right we got public reception
yeah public reception so Rolling Stone
posted their own thing this is after
they posted their article they did an
update it said in true Millennial cringe
fashion Colleen Ballinger has finally
responded to allegations of toxic
behavior in a 10-minute YouTube ukulele
song
um part yeah literally heart
um Adam said in all seriousness
Colleen's video is a perfect example of
how she has no good ideas herself they
all come from her underage fans she
bothers for them
um as much as Colleen discredited made
fun of me I'm glad her video did one
thing show you all exactly the type of
evil woman she is that a lot of us have
experienced over the past few years
behind the scenes The Mask has slipped
everyone meet the real Colleen Ballinger
okay that has 145 000 likes Adam I'm
afraid for your safety man she's gonna
put a hit on you or something you'll see
she's already she's hired a lawyer oh
she did he did oh bro
Anissa posted Colleen waiter for the H3
podcast to take a two-week break before
dropping that sick Millennial ukulele
solo track I'm so sure of it I would
like to believe it well we're here now
we're here now with um [__] me right 86
000 watch things uh oh my God it didn't
save her from anything
let's go
okay this is Tana's response
Friends of the show
[Music]
there is no way that is a real video
yeah that's I know man it's really
something
Ethan's fave response yeah the memes
that you this is so good this is Colleen
AF
Ghan sorry sir
to my mother
my mother oh my God
so the victim I'm sorry sorry
[Music]
yeah that's more apologizing than she
did Yes
actually yeah this is a more thorough
apology
did he kill someone because that would
be epic
to the victim to the mother I'm sorry
holy [__] yeah that's great that's good
uh oh the Baja Blast is in the house oh
[__]
here's another of my fave response thank
you got a Baja Blast in it the goddamn
house
fact check she's PG-13 it says on my
website it's always been that way okay
so 2018 they did the way back machine
nothing's there right wait how does that
help her case no it doesn't they're
proving it wrong
and then in the next one it shows that
she added it way later
she added it in 2018 which frankly in my
opinion impressive but she added that
it's PG-13 yes but she started live
touring in 2012. it's always been that
way I've always been PG-13 but that
disclaimer was added to her website in
2018. it's but I it's all ages it
doesn't matter right even if it was
PG-13 the people that she did this to
were like 14.
so they're of age that's what I'm saying
at all no yeah here's another Colleen
apology meme that I loved
see
be clear I did not write that song
this is the best although this is sunny
are we here for this eventually all
right I mean it's really short but stop
it potentially that was it yeah it was
pretty short
it's probably fine but Ethan's fan oh
like okay we got a lot of good ones here
this one uh this one went big on tick
tock I like this one
[Music]
I won't take accountability I'm not
gonna change I waited for the History
Podcast thank you girl shout out oh
[Music]
she's a shoe-in
YouTube's most deranged I think she's
gonna sweep this year
[Music]
but I shouldn't have been canceled a
really long time ago
my own children just so I can go viral I
don't know why what do you guys think
I'm such a horrible person when I was
thinking about what organization I could
crowdfund donations for you know because
I'm a kind caring person
I didn't need the tax write-offs
so I thought it would make me look the
best something with the children
children with cancer that's pretty bad
we'll go with that wait what is she
talking about that's yeah I don't know
so she Colleen for her birthday every
year she does a fundraiser for Childhood
Cancer and a lot of people have been
pointing out that she doesn't provide
receipts and also it doesn't
um it hits her bank account first before
it gets no stealing the children's
cancer
why would she set it up like that is
wait hold on
oh no one's ever done it better folks
wait how did you set up oh yeah how did
she set that up where it hits her bank
account first that's wild I want to see
I want to oh yeah what are we talking
about
the human fun
all proceeds to the human fun
cavitat you for Humanity gets one
million dollars
okay I didn't know about all that yeah
yeah so if they're sending her the money
she has a point then she can make the
donation and write it off yeah as a as a
business expense but also if it hits her
first doesn't she get taxed on it
it just seems like a bad way to do it
all around right yes yeah definitely
yeah oh yeah definitely the worst way to
do it yeah I guess you would write it
off because it's technically probably
would be considered income
what a Twist no yes that's a that's a
crazy part when you thought it couldn't
get any crazier okay I'm not gonna say
sorry for laughing dog down
oh God what wait we have to watch that
one dog clip oh it's it's right here
it's on the right on this slide okay it
says the dog story oh my God
the dog story is the worst thing ever no
no anyway shout out girl um to uh what's
your name emro ham
Ro ham clearly a fan of the show
who we love
God
let's see secrets and self-help by
Miranda Sings and Colleen Ballinger on
YouTube search secrets of self-help okay
there's all these little secrets there's
mistake on this page
um how to draw a hot dog there's mistake
and I'm really bummed there's a mistake
on every page but there's like truly a
mistake on this page so it teaches you
how to draw a hot dog when it's supposed
to look like a vagina the fifth step is
to add ketchup
and I wanted ketchup on the page but we
forgot to add it and so because I wanted
to look like a nasty vagina with blood
on it because I'm a pervert I wanted to
and that's pretty gross
pretty gnarly isn't it yep
it's kind of interesting because a lot
of her fans were probably girls who are
about to or recently got there started
menstruating
speaking right to them interesting
the dog story is the worst thing ever
this is the worst thing yeah you know
she addressed it in her 2020 apology
which people were like okay
I linked you to it in the in the doc but
watch the video first so people know
this I saw this before the uke song and
everything and I was like whoa this is
really dark
check this out and I have like anger
management problems there are times
where I'm just like I just feel like I
need to hit something or like screaming
a pillow I used to like actually like
rip things up or get angry so I grabbed
my dog for no reason just grabbed the
dog and pinched its skin and dug my
nails into it so dumb Yelps turns around
protects itself and bites me in the face
and I got stitches I went to the
hospital and they were like what
happened and I was like the dog just bit
me and then they had to put the dog to
sleep because the dog was dangerous to
be around
the thing
oh my God I take back anything I [__]
said nice about her [__] apology
video wait and there's like a fun music
here yeah no she's telling it like it's
a funny silly story I mean I'm not done
here you got to watch this I was jaw jaw
on the ground thank you the dog was
dangerous to be around so I murdered
[Music]
can you believe that no now it happened
when she was a kid but obviously that's
not the point it's the point of how
she's reading how she's she's showing
the story like it's funny
isn't that so [__] up I mean somebody
talk like that about my dog it's on
so is that music in the original do you
know Olivia or is that I'm pretty that
is the music that she would use it was a
fun silly story
yeah she would do every every Tuesday
Friday she did something called
Colleen's corner or maybe it was just
Tuesday and um she would answer
questions and that's usually the music
she would use underneath no nice way
yeah
it made me so mad I can't believe it but
I did I linked you her
I linked her explanation for it okay she
set it up or something because that
would be
the only way to address that did she
bust out the uke but the way she came
out of this video unscathed I don't get
it I mean did she deny that it was a
real story
I did not [__] my cat I did not [__] my
cat I did not come anywhere near my cat
okay let me watch this I'm curious there
are weeks all over my house right now
brand new oh wait no no that's not it I
linked it in Discord oh thank you
uh he did not come on my door
but a doctor said that legally the dog
need to be put down [__] now this is
me that is circulating from seven years
ago is me talking about this situation
in a very insensitive way when in
reality when our dog was put down I was
really upset and over the years I have
addressed this a few times in videos
talking about how guilty I feel how
upset I am that this happened still to
this day as a 33 year old woman I feel
guilty that our dog had to be put down
providing me but I had a hard time the
rest of the weekend
but the problem is that you made it up
yeah
in this apology she's making it sound
like she felt so guilty because this dog
had to be put down because it bit her
she does not mention the fact that she
was physically torturing the dog when it
bit her right
right so look if that starts with true I
would carry a men's skill I would never
tell that story I probably would never
tell it yeah
it would be like toxic okay here's the
worst thing on me
holy [__]
that Fried Chicken one's kind of good
love oh yeah dude it's so good really
good eating it right now why is that
chicken so good it's weird let's talk
about dealing with that yeah I don't
know
how do you know what to order you just
got here
that's what I'm saying myself to love
ordering some weird [__] I was like I
need that dude I've had to talk about
five times already
what what you say
sorry I don't know how to talk about
five times
[Music]
um
so what's this one
this one is like what could have
warranted this I'm physically sick okay
I'm in and every time it rains it leaks
oh yeah I've seen this just like a
teenage girls
I can't remember when I say this it
leaks so much like a little girl's
greases when she watches me
like a little girl's creases when she's
watching show us
Maui
that's why she why does she make jokes
like that why is she so obsessed with
that kind of stuff I think she's I'm
making me very uncomfortable yeah yeah
all right moving along
moving right along yes why are you like
this Colleen well I know the dancer
unfortunately and I'm
I'm speculating I don't know anything
about this and
but it does seem like
there's some deep deep deep issues going
on in that family yeah from her brother
the pedo mm-hmm her
boundary issues her dad watching
inflation for I mean nothing there's
anything wrong with that [__] me right
want
all right so
this is something we found we found
um a resurfaced Twitter thread of a man
who clearly watched Miranda sings on
YouTube with his wife thought that she
was an adult comedian went to a Miranda
sings show and tweeted about how he was
like I'm very confused like this this
comedian I watch is like very
inappropriate and then he just like went
along and he was like
she wants help from the crowd to perform
her own birth children are going ape
[__] a shy looking teenage boy from the
audience is going to play the role of
her mother like it was just crazy and he
was just flabbergasted about this is
really interesting because
it really gives you a time capsule like
back to 2018 someone from the outside
came and witnessed this and saw how
[__] crazy it was even then really
interesting yep so yeah here let me let
me read this all right 2018 April
so this is I guess before her disclaimer
was on her website right
um wife and I got tickets to see a
comedian we really like I was already
like huh
you got tickets to see who
the entire crowd are children and their
parents we are very confused we are two
third year olds sitting in the ground
drinking beer you can get beer there
that's so crazy and getting weird looks
it's gonna be awkward here here's the
thread
guardi have plans on how to evacuate in
case this is indeed a show for kids this
is one of the most awkward moments of my
life
average age in a row 10.
including us
did nobody tell them this is PG-13
children are wooing and clapping like
crazy lights are still on show didn't
start do other people our age walk in
they look just as shocked as we are all
the parents are drinking all of them
cheers well dude maybe that's why this
was allowed to go on so long I mean
maybe and also if you got dragged along
to this by your 10 year old you'd
probably want something to get trashed
and then drive home ease the pain a
little bit
um
she's starting the children are
screaming I'm deaf she just said
something about eating Tide Pods don't
you know where the [__] is going very
timely holy [__] you just called one of
the moms at dick oh my God
this is definitely not a show for kids
again this is so interesting in 2018
this guy was like
this is crazy
theater is filled with shocked and
pissed off parents oh my God this is
amazing not even the children understand
our jokes parents are shocked and we're
just sitting here drinking beer
there's a whole monologue about porn
going on all the parents decide children
are cheering this is beyond amazing
she just brought a girl from the
audience on stage and told her that
she's dressed like porn this is so
amazing the word testicle crack was said
she just asked for boys to come on stage
dads one and two there's not enough
popcorn in the world what the hell is
this there is wait what
she wasn't kidding
this Dad is involved
maybe he's just riding for his daughter
and trying to make it yeah probably
um
let's see
here we are never in my life I've seen
so many shock parents and children that
have no freaking idea about what they're
laughing and cheering about wife just
finished her beer and the mom who sits
next to us gave her the stink eye a
trump joke was said children are
cheering parents are shocked
she wants help from a crowd to perform
her own birth
children are going ape [__] a
shy-looking teenage boy from the
audience is going to play the role of
her mother
her what is the smell Mom are you
cooking cabbage boy reading from a
script no this is My Placenta just heard
the mom next to us say what the [__]
now it's a giant parody of Disney songs
children are losing their minds
fun card
again the crowd are kids this is amazing
here it is a comment
I hope you [__] die
um
it's time for the great reveal
uh Kim guessed it it's Miranda Sings
Colleen Ballinger This Thread is far
from over it one man mom is dragging her
daughter out of the theater oh dear lord
period jokes mom next to us covered her
seven-year-old's ears
the show's over uh Colleen is a role
model for every child in this world wow
just [__] wow
that's super interesting
yeah
what comedian not ready to reveal yet
but he posted pictures right
that must be out of order
no you no
well anyway very interesting
okay so then
Colleen's unsurprisingly racist past
surfaces first let's get this part out
of the way because it shouldn't
discredit all of the credible claims
obviously and this is the only thing
that her legal team has responded to
seriously yes that's lame I know all
aboard
so people were accusing
um Colleen of doing blackface this is a
uh if it's a pretty bad decision in the
anyway to be recreating Beyonce's
um Single Ladies routine with anything
on your face however I do know that she
would do the wicked uh song uh Defying
Gravity at the beginning of all her
shows
um which is what her legal team says but
when I was a Miranda fan she did not do
green face paint but maybe she did in
her earlier years wait so you're saying
it was like green witch makeup yeah when
I saw this I zoomed in there's frames
you can see it's green
but that was my reaction too I was like
why are we
there's so much yeah why do we have
there's other credible racist
allegations that we will get to actually
right after this ah okay so she's in
witch face so side note
um
uh This legal reps resume is pretty
scary
Prince
yeah I remember really stopped oh no oh
yeah which was burning changed right
right right right
sorry Olivia oh good I absolutely
[Applause]
um so Colleen's lawyer has also
represented people like Army Hammer and
prince Andrew whoa yes
so who's who of Epstein's Island uh
who's who of child Predators wait hold
on how do you know that oh there's
articles yeah
because the yeah her lawyer released a
statement that she was doing Wicked face
and not black she was doing Wicked face
I love to see this guy's commercials
he's like I specialize in defending
people from accusations of pedophilia
and child abuse if you've been accused
of raping a child call me now
all right so the credible racist
allegations April
was a showrunner assistant on Colleen's
show haters back off
um and she released an op-ed called um
on cancel culture Academy you owe me an
apology on cancel culture accountability
and being in the writer's room with
Miranda Sings
and if we continue this is from June
30th so this happened after yes all this
um Colleen Ballinger reportedly insisted
on her Netflix series haters back off
having limited background actors of
color on set because it would be
distracting for a show set in Washington
huh this was said by um
why would that be by April in her in her
piece
right I don't know too many black people
walking around this is in Washington I
don't buy it wait what my suspension of
disbelief is so disruptive this just
took me right out of the show one two
there's another black person that's the
third black person to walk back in
Washington absolutely I am black wait is
there no black dad this is real
according to the this I don't know girl
who woman Northwest is pretty white but
I I there are definitely black people
she worked on the set so and she's
saying that that's what she said
crazy
yes um a story that was told in this
piece another one was that they were
watching audition tapes and there was a
black man who auditioned and Colleen
like pointed at the screen and was like
I can't even see him in reference to how
dark he was
that's insane
nice that's yep yep yep yeah Washington
five percent ish but we need we need to
make sure we have exactly five percent
black people it's total immersion
he takes that five times another uh the
first thing I notice when I watch a show
is the density of black people
right yeah I'm I'm taking notes
uh the next background actors not even
just the cast we're specifically talking
about extras yeah in the background this
is really I'm honing in on that mm-hmm
wait go back one
um Colleen Ballinger reportedly had an
Asian market redressed as a bodega for
her Netflix series haters back off and
demanded in in quotes that all the Asian
[__] be removed before filming nice
choice of photos
Asian market redress as a bodega I mean
that's fine they just they're real space
she says just get rid of all the Asian
[__] yeah
okay another thing the show runner's
assistant
um
April she said uh
that Colleen was obsessed with adding
incest references which yes has checked
out through her content 100 she
allegedly pitched stories in which
Miranda and her uncle would be caught in
compromising positions or stomach
turning moments of intimacy which I can
attest to that does happen in the show
yeah she's got a weird thing for that
stuff
okay so now we'll get to the part
about Colleen Ballinger's cruelty
against Trisha
um if you didn't know they started a
podcast at the towards the end of May
and it ran for three episodes and
I actually got to three I thought I'd
only had like one or two I gotta say it
makes Frenemies look like The Simpsons
with dogs yeah longest longest lasting
podcast
39 episodes
yes so they built a set in Trisha's
basement and they started
this podcast together and something that
came out over the break I know that Adam
had been insinuating it like when he was
watching the podcast back and he would
like do reaction videos he would
say like calling used to be mean about
Trisha like he would say that and um
I totally obviously understand
um there was no proof given blah blah
blah and then now this proof was posted
by Johnny that showed Colleen would host
viewing parties with her friends to
watch Trisha's not safe for work and
they're supposed to be friends right so
I recognize this friend in this photo
and Trisha said that she's actually hung
out with him before so this is Colleen's
friend from college and
um she says to Johnny who was her
ex-employee and much younger than her
not a minor at the time
um she would always send him like naked
photos of Trisha from her only fans and
insinuate that like they were photos of
him and she would be like you look so
cute today and so Johnny
posted them so that
people could see that there was proof
and um if you go to the next slide
actually ironically this was just taken
a few weeks ago this is Colleen talking
to Trisha about body positivity
oh what happened
that's weird
all aboard
yeah and I guess or Trisha well I guess
we have Trisha's response in here too
right we do yeah we got all the receipts
oh got it you've got it all every single
receipt
entertaining okay
sent it in Discord
thank you
to bring up someone's body like you know
what you ever talk about anyone's body
ever I don't think I think it's
completely inappropriate and wrong and
every body size and shape is beautiful
wow that's insane and so the thing that
struck me about the making fun of her
only fans
was that it wasn't that long ago
right right it was like in this here let
me look at the dates in this decade it
was she had had her baby
who
oh she had had it so yeah that's really
recently and had her baby there's like
one screenshot where Johnny's like
congratulations to your parents now and
then she doesn't answer and then she
sends a nude and says Johnny looks so
cute here are they
it's just very here's the bad girl
moment disturbing
yes so now we know that um
Adam said in a few videos that actually
what Trisha
thought had happened but they were
joking about it is actually what
happened and that was that she was given
the wrong address to Colleen's house
when they were hanging out so this like
what she gave Tricia the wrong address
on purpose yeah that is so insane and
this is like a clip of
heard now we know it's not an action she
literally did give the wrong address to
make fun of Trisha that is like the
meanest thing mean girl High School
[__] ever yep
[Laughter]
right there she's like I did that [__]
but how do we know that she did it on
purpose
well Adam says that it was on purpose oh
he okay I see yes this is when Adam and
Colleen were selling communities
oh my God it's like Mean Girls like
they're like making fun of me
yeah just like this is funny
yeah like I drive all the way out here
well that's crazy if she actually did on
purpose and then filmed this yeah nobody
deserves it in my bony little back why
they bowling Trish oh my God it's so
mean
y'all got me feeling bad for Trisha
Paytas out here
foreign
video what's this one oh that's the the
whale tale video
a whale we saw a whale we saw a whale
tail and I'm not talking some girl whose
song is hanging out of her pants I'm
talking about an actual whale sale
yeah we did the square and I'm not
talking about Trisha Paytas wait what is
this in the video yeah dude she's she
wow okay
very interesting
okay so all right well this is when
Trisha posted her she came back The
Queen Is Back
yes I mean she hasn't posted a tea video
like this in so long and I knew
this one was gonna be hard to resist boy
I will say
it is little she was very calm I think
it was a really mature
and thoughtful response
she there was no crying pissing [__]
or squealing
but I'm more embarrassed for her that
this is the kind of person she is like
I'm
I'm so embarrassed
sending these to fans unsolicited the
context of which she was sending these
it's all like this so yeah I don't you
know what I mean yeah it's just this for
20 minutes so um just a few things we
learned in that video about Colleen
um or first of all Trisha denounces
everything about Colleen in that video
um she says that she's never going to
speak Colleen's name again she's
basically dead to her Colleen texted her
the uke video beforehand we learned that
Trisha says she didn't answer
um
Trisha asked Colleen about so when Adam
and Johnny were saying that they had
been sent porn of Trisha
um and they weren't providing proof
um apparently Trisha approached Colleen
and asked if that was true and Colleen
actually blamed it on the kids and said
that they were sending it to her
which is crazy right and then that's
when he jack put out the receipts right
so just a few weeks ago Colleen was
lying about all I mean Colleen's still
lying about all of this let's be real
right and before I feel too um
before we feel too bad for Trisha
she did also allegedly
uh I'm not even gonna go but she
Trisha's not a saint
right
you know what I mean she she it's nice
that she can be mature when it benefits
her
but I know this is impressive this is
all about Colleen these are Colleen's
actions and
the destructiveness that they are
or have been well done
um thank you uh so the next slide um
this is or here if you go back
uh they're selling the podcast set
oh yeah she's trying to sell the chair
the podcast set it's like Kramer with
the with the extra sitcoms honestly we
just honestly I know someone that needs
a new chair right oh [__] that would be
kind of iconic yeah kind of funny you in
them should we buy it and uh just throw
it over where we have the Frenemies
table over there we can have a whole
museum of dead podcasts well that's
funny because Trisha you know how she
was like collecting Adam Sandler's
clothes we could be collecting Trisha's
sets of our other canceled podcasts
who's your next podcast uh
co-host going to be Trisha
uh G Lane Maxwell
[Music]
no it's not bad
taking it out
I'm playing it safe oh man the toxic
concentrate let's move on Pastor Jim
yeah
I just buttoned myself to him I just
call it a day
so here we go next slide
okay so these are the kids just some of
the kids that have been affected by
Colleen and the Ballinger Family that's
Adam obviously Adam
um he's not here to talk to us today
Johnny
um he is going to be talking to us he uh
worked on Colleen's bus tour he was a
huge fan met them when he was 15 years
old 16 years old I think started
watching when he was 15.
um Becky was brought on to Stage
exploited and obviously has been dealing
with it since and Oliver was
speaking with
and Trent Ballinger and an old man when
he was just 13. so I just sent them the
zoom link so okay so I have all three
standing by would you I'm so I have to
pee so bad oh right back I'm all right
you do that
and then we'll get it going I guess um
we have not been paying much attention
to the chat today so let me uh try and
acknowledge some of the many super chats
and messages from you'd find people out
there
uh specifically pull up my Super Chat
log
here it comes here it comes standby all
aboard All Aboard all aboard
okay here we go
okay
I'm gonna get through as many as I can
um there is a video of Colleen Miranda
putting her cat in a paper bag and
watching it struggle oh I have seen that
cool girl I've seen everything cool I'm
a vile person uh somebody donated 10
bucks and said for cam making me laugh
so hard I cried yeah that was that's
good [__] shout out to Cameron oh he's
gone shout out to Cameron Grands out
shot on the toxic [__] amazing uh
let's see
um
also can we recognize marketing content
as PG-13 doesn't give you a pass to
harass kids 13 is still a kid yeah yeah
that whole thing was very odd to me I'm
not really sure 13. also really quickly
um it is so brave of these people to
come on the show and talk about their
stories so give them extra love in chat
please please please
uh
a 10 donation he definitely helped write
it I'm assuming we're talking about Lim
Manuel uh there are certain lines in
there that are way too clever for her to
have written I mean I'm just gonna head
cannon that he was involved because this
is funny as [__] to think that's
horrible but I believe it I believe is
the thing uh 20 donation we missed Ethan
and Daniel and the crew down there
I hell yeah oh the devil that was from
the devil I was like what does he mean
by down there thanks devil
uh five dollars what is a b wearing I
love it and I need it it's a new Teddy
fresh item that's coming out later this
week
so pick one up
for yourself
uh let's see uh here's another 20 it's
my 21st birthday I couldn't figure out
how to verify my account on Discord to
verify with Zach so I just made it my
profile picture oh my God they did they
actually have thread because their
YouTube icon that is very all right
that's dedication Zach every single one
says we're 21.
21 year olds you think they're on this
town
guys don't do that 21 [__] you there it
is 21 drama continues thank you this
person put they couldn't figure out how
to get on Discord so they put their ID
that has their profile picture on
YouTube so shout out that that's
dedicated yeah I'll give you that Zach
almost even denied that this is Hardcore
but you're the keeper I won't tell you
how to do your jobs there all right the
one last one 20 donation you guys were
on break during my birthday on the
fourth and I turned 27 zilizanka can I
get a happy birthday please give me
seven
being at Disneyland were people doing
that yeah people I actually did look
people were leaving very nasty comments
like
he's at Disneyland it was planned having
fun why would they be mad that he didn't
I mean there were people saying that
like he's refusing to stand with the
victims it was just ridiculous literally
yeah I don't know who I I sometimes when
I'm already crazy sometimes when I see
that [__] that is just so ignorant and
mean-spirited and like who are these
people I swear sometimes I feel like
there are communities being infiltrated
yeah the false flag I agree I agree it's
they're crazy because that's just like
comic book stupid yep yep yep and Dan
ruin my hope I was about to say I'm not
trying to ruin another person's Disney
trip okay don't put that on me
donated two bucks and said I can't stand
it he posted a screenshot of of Dan at
the beginning of the show and said Dan
looking greatness Teddy press I love
rage
truce Rich I've turned around on Rich
too I think the sound box sound bites
are my pride yeah and looking good in
his Teddy fresh shirt hashtag Dan
love it hashtag dance girl Dan the house
she just said damn the house
cheers my dude we love Rich all right
all right uh but yeah I mean obviously
people on standby in the lobby would you
like me please okay yeah about Adam I
don't it's like I have a hard time
believing that any of our fans who
actively watched his show would be that
ignorant and mean yeah it's
the red is full of
scary scary goobers bunch of goobers I'm
glad you you believe in the false flag
too love yeah no I I think it's like
people just troll ing trying to [__]
around just
for fun I don't know
hello everybody we have Oliver Becky and
Johnny welcome to the show guys thank
you for standing by I am sorry it took
so long but I appreciate you guys uh uh
standing back and standing by As Trump
said
so um
um let's see so we have um
Johnny
hi you used to work for Colleen on your
tour
and then we have Becky
Becky you are you're the girl from this
the infamous story of the uh the
the skirt situation
I don't know how to put it delicately it
doesn't sound horrible
yeah and then Oliver you are
the unfortunate recipient of
some really wild yeah messages oh yeah
tell me about it so anyway thank you for
coming together guys are you guys all
weenies
no no no
none of you guys are weenies someone
thought I was but no
oh that's interesting so there's so many
more people out there oh there's a lot
yes
so first I guess uh Johnny so how did
you get recruited into
uh working for her
um well I actually started watching her
videos and tuning in
2012 I was 15 and I started entering
tiny chat rooms I created a fan account
and I was met with a bunch of people my
age who were like-minded and we enjoyed
this character and it turned into
a very inappropriate
um
situation and power dynamic between them
and us
um and I I was like a part of the OG
fandom like we weren't the weenies or
anything we were the cookies is the name
that we so wait yeah so so you
joined a community with other fans so
what was the plow the power Dynamic well
I'm not understanding they were
Colleen's Camp was involved in that
somehow
so it started because I was tweeting her
off of my personal account but then I
started getting flat because I was just
in high school so kids would make fun of
me for it so I like created this private
Twitter account I created my own fan
account and then I had followed there
was probably maybe like four to five
other fan accounts we all followed each
other I saw that three of the girls
um Behind These accounts who were all
like my age they would Skype Colleen and
I was like
okay sorry just to clarify this is a
different
Colleen chat group it's different
Generations oh wow okay yeah that's why
I said wow I didn't know that yeah yeah
it's been going on for years
and so okay so were you on like voice
chat with her or like a chat room yeah
so tying chat was basically this it's um
like a public Skype Zoom type of
situation and
um you could either have a public
profile or you know uh public chat room
or you could have it private ours was
tinychat.com Colleen's cookies the
password that we had to type in to get
into the room was queefing that's how I
learned what that word was awesome
um
and we would be okay let's say
if I was chatting with my
14 to 17 year old friends as a 15 year
old during this time period if we were
on Tiny chat seven days a week
Colleen
her ex-husband Joshua her brother Trent
um it was like the three of them were
the repeat offenders they would just be
on at least like four to five times a
week with us wow wow so okay that's
that's interesting to know too that her
brother
who was the one messaging you Oliver had
access and obviously he must have been
granted access
yes kind of kind of he actually he got
scolded for talking to my friends and I
back in the day and we found that out
because Colleen had come on Tiny chat
and told us one day that her parents
um
had a talk with him because he lived at
home and this was before he had gotten
his cochlear implant which helps him
here now he was born deaf
um before that he couldn't hear so he
didn't understand
um he had to mute his computer
um so her parents were afraid that there
would be
you know sensitive topics being
discussed you know within their family
that would be picked up on his computer
um it's kind of messed up that that was
their concern rather than their
30-something year old child talking to a
bunch of kids on the internet but also
what are they talking about in the house
that's that's so scary I mean are we
really surprised that like no I don't
want to know and so
um were either the other two of you in a
chat room with Colleen at any point no
no no and so I guess Jack what do you
think they that she got out of coming on
here and talking with you guys like she
came on sounds like pretty frequently
um
you know it's interesting because we
really don't know what her motives were
um I've been asked to
try to describe it in one word I think
the power that keeps coming to mind is
um Power
um which she clearly abused I'm not sure
if she went into this situation you know
me and my friends who were fans way back
in the day I don't think it was as
malicious back then but as we know
technology has blossomed and it's just
there's more accessibility it's so much
easier to be in the DMS film a quick
video video chat like this and uh
yeah it was just uh
a different world but there's a lot of
parallels from the video chats and the
DM conversations between the Weenies and
Corey's [__] and so I'm looking back on
that and what way do you how how is she
like abusing her power or how was she
interacting with you guys
inappropriately now that you're now that
you're older and looking back on it
in the sense that
and Joshua her ex
they divided the fandom a lot even
before they were married
I wasn't always the closest with Colleen
I was way way closer with Joshua David
Evans he really swooped in and that's a
whole leather tangent but they would
almost like pit us against each other as
fans they would put us against one
another like you'd be team Josh team
Colleen throughout their entire
relationship it was like that I I knew
some people who way back in the day said
they did not like him and I didn't
understand I liked both of them it was
weird and sometimes we'd end up fighting
online for them and it would be
encouraged Pauline used to use a hashtag
that we came up with it was drama with
like five extra A's so you could look it
up and see like back in the day she used
to use this hashtag and it was always
when there was like drama within the
fandom it encouraged it it's it's like
she egged it on for us so it didn't feel
like a joke at the time it felt like she
was like yeah I want you guys to hate
Josh well now it feels that way but as a
child it kind of just felt playful just
felt like our
um in her words just felt like our
creepy Aunt coming up just trying to
hang out with those kids and
you know it's a weird way to spend your
time as an adult right I'm 27 now which
I believe is the age she was when she
started talking to me and there's
no part of me that wants to open up my
laptop right yeah it's like spectate
their conversations because Tinychat had
that option there could be
like the four of us in the chat room
right now or five
um and then there could be Spectators
and they can chat but they don't
necessarily have to broadcast and
um they abused that feature there's
actually evidence that I posted of
Joshua pretending to be me talking some
friends as if he was me and he then
broadcasted after however long he stayed
on that night clearly I wasn't on all of
them thought it was me and then so your
relationship with Josh is is interesting
and weird to me because I I've seen
people talking about him as like oh he's
innocent now and he's a victim of hers
because I don't know anything about him
or their previous relationship but I
read that he was talking to you in the
same way that Colleen was talking to
other people and I was like yo what what
the [__] is this so how did he reach out
to you and what was that relationship
like
so honestly in 2012 we would primarily
tiny chat with Colleen and Trent
Josh would pop in every once in a while
but he would only do it like if it was
with Colleen it was very very rare that
he would just come on by himself unless
he was a spectator even more than we had
realized but like actually broadcasting
wasn't super often so I my parents uh I
was just having a shitty time in school
which is kind of why I gravitated
towards this online world and so my
parents were like you know what let's do
something special for the holidays and
Christmas 2012 uh she was doing a show
in New York City and at the time she
either did West Coast or east coast and
I was in Illinois so I had to pick one
if I wanted to go so we made a little
trip out of it and then that is the
evening of the infamous Crown oh
thank you
the infamous crown that I was given
um that is signed by oh I don't want to
show the phone number on the back but
Miranda Colleen and Josh himself and
they just went down the line and signed
it and then afterwards he flipped it
open and kept writing and I was kind of
like what and then he handed it to me
and just kind of gave me like a little
nod of affirmation and was just kind of
like use it whenever you need huh wow
that is the weirdest [__] ever this man
gave you his phone number and said text
me I was 16. yeah wow wow [__] yeah did
he know who you were or that you were in
that chat
yes but see the thing is I was really
flattered about it because I thought
Colleen would be more excited to see me
and meet me but I felt like I had this
like weird instant connection with Josh
in person and then I was like okay well
Colleen's kind of fixated on like
her babes if you will and I didn't
really feel like one of them I was just
known within the fandom and I was like
well Josh seems to really like me and he
started giving me promises
um he incorporate he pinned my YouTube
channel my little aspiring one back in
the day on his channel that eventually
accumulated like 1.5 million subscribers
that was a massive deal to me like I got
bullied out of high school my sophomore
year and these people just honed in on
me and they were like oh like
this is good he's an easy target and I
was and
yeah they just totally
abused their power in that sense they
take who they deem as weak vulnerable
people
and they create the victims or they they
turn you into more of a victim but they
also do it in a way where they pretend
to be your savior a lot and it creates a
very abusive
Dynamic especially for a teen going into
adulthood it followed me clearly I
didn't work for them until I was 22
years old and looking back now I'm like
I was an adult I'm ashamed of that but
it's what I was
brought up to believe was right and
wrong and I was just influenced
I want to ask you a question going back
to when he handed you the number so yeah
so you when did you reach out to him and
how did you reach out to him how long
was it after you got it yeah so um I
somewhat revived a dead laptop of mine
but it's
it's on Life Alert like it's it comes
and goes so I think I have more texts
that I could go back and find I believe
on that night I I sent him something
like hey thanks for your number this
means a lot to me
um I think I even included something
like I promise not to abuse it and just
use it when needed because I took it as
he was gonna be a mentor as he says
today but that's not what it was and
um
I yeah I and did he respond to you that
evening he did okay and then you guys
started texting like on a one-on-one
basis not super regularly because I
didn't want to abuse it I didn't want to
lose this privilege because they like
gave you little things but then would
kind of hold it over your head even if
they didn't say it to your face they
would it was heavily implied so you you
had said that he said he wanted to be
your Mentor so how what is it that you
think he he got out of that relationship
with you
well I only just found out like a week
ago that he was trying to be my mentor
when he publicly stated that because he
was just my big bro he was he was my my
you know
30 year old BFF I didn't know he was
trying to Mentor me I thought I was in a
friendship and I was that in my world
um and uh
yeah that whole dynamic it's just he had
me run a Twitter account for him it was
a character that he ran
um a belligerent drunk
blonde bimbo if you will by the name of
Sarah diculus
who is problematic Beyond I I'm sure of
it I haven't even re-watched any of the
videos recently but I'm sure that would
spark up some combo
um and I ran this Twitter account for
him he approached me and he asked if I
would run it because I was running a
fake account I had I had created
um
like a spoof of Sarah diculus and he
contacted one of our friends who he
thought was running it and was like hey
you want to run the official one and she
was like no it's Johnny so he came to me
and was like do you want to run the
official one and I was like hell yeah
and he gave me the password the username
and he was like your discretion I'll pop
in from time to time I might you know
interact on the account and stuff but
it's all you it was it was what Colleen
said to Adam that's what's interesting
it seems parallel where they both ask
you and Adam to do free work for them
did he ever offer to pay you or
compensate you or anything like that
no but he always promised me things in
the future it was always if I played my
cards right I was pinned on his YouTube
channel I'd be featured in little you
know BS YouTube videos from time to time
uh he would say things like if I ever
make it big I'm taking you with me we're
gonna make it big together and I was
just impressionable and I believed him
for sure wholeheartedly did you put a
lot of time into running that Twitter
account
not just the Twitter account just
investing so much time and energy into
my relationship with not only him but
these people in general yeah I
the best way I can describe it is you
know not fitting in in school constantly
feeling like I'm chasing the cool kids I
finally escaped that and found a world
that I did feel accepted in but I didn't
realize that I was just chasing the cool
kids in a completely different way
that it's embarrassing to say followed
me into adulthood
and it just turned into like this cycle
you know something that struck me as
interesting is when Josh and Colleen got
divorced
you say that josh stop talking to you
all together in that moment right
yeah so they announced their divorce and
I remember like my entire family was
devastated like my mom cried because
they built relationships with my parents
too Colleen referred to my mom as her
Chicago mom sometimes Josh we went to
dinner with him and then they hung out
with him too like my parents my two
older sisters one's 42 one's 40. there's
a big age gap between me and my youngest
sister so my parents are kind of used to
having different Generations in the
family and they really kind of took
these people and kind of like their own
and I say that lightly because you know
it's not like they had this massive
relationship with these people but it
was someone who I trusted and because
they knew I was dealing with such
BS
you know in the real world you can fight
it in him a lot yeah yeah yeah it's just
messy how not only did they prey on us
kids but they really went above and
beyond to like prove to the parents that
they were safe people as well that's
really wild that they spent time with
your family like that yeah she like
tries to say it's it's it's a lot more
minimal than it was which is infuriating
um so when Josh was it like he
immediately ghosted you when once they
divorced and he never wrote you back
again
yeah so they got divorced I remember I
was just trying to like take care of my
YouTube parents on the internet and see
from both sides and in the process of
doing that I went to his channel and my
my my channel was unpinned along with
all of the ballingers and I was like
well why was I clumped in
and uh
uh he just completely cut me out I was
trying to message him I texted him and
was like I'm I'm sorry did I say
something to upset you like
I yes I started off as a fan of Colleen
but like you're like a brother to me
like
don't leave me dude come on you said we
we'd go somewhere together I was
heartbroken it felt like I was going
through some weird effed up breakup and
I was still only like
I think I was like 18 at the time so I
was just entering adulthood it was a
really confusing time for me and he just
completely Left Behind drive it's pretty
so like a week later yeah I made a
public statement on the Sarah ridiculous
account that I didn't feel right running
it any longer
um I didn't really elaborate at the time
because I didn't want to destroy my
friendship
with Colleen
um
but yeah then the next time I heard from
Joshua David Evans was last month when
he was trying to damage control his way
into my life
so I'm sensing that a lot of the kind of
the the uh negative feelings associated
with this is just the way he discarded
you at the end after you really
seem to have built what you perceived as
a meaningful relationship with them
I almost felt like he got what he needed
out of me and then he was just done
because I also there's a story about how
I came out to him one night when I flew
all the way out to California to see one
of his shows and that was only like 17
and I wasn't out publicly yet or like at
least to like my family
and I told him that I wanted to tell my
parents I first had come out to him
which he responded with that's none of
my business and I was like oh God and
then I tried to give him Redemption and
I was like well I'm gonna tell my
parents what do you think about that and
he was like
I'm I'm worried for you I'm nervous for
you I wouldn't do that that's wild and
personally
what's that was that in person yeah yeah
and there was another witness there who
heard that he was like at the time
where do you think that came from
I described it to swoop who's been doing
a docu series on this as I feel like it
was the moment of him being like oh [__]
this kid's turning 18 in a couple days
he's coming into his own I don't I'm
losing control that's how I feel in
hindsight like just the fear in his eyes
it wasn't like uh oh that's none of my
business like you do you kiddo it was
like
well that's not my business and I'm I'm
just I can see it in my brain it's like
scarred and it just
I don't know it felt like a moment of
loss of control and him kind of not
knowing what to do and panicking and I
don't know
yeah I always wondered because I
wondered if he how much him and Colleen
talked about
like his relationship with you and her
relationship with other folks
because there seems to be a parallel and
I wonder if she knew or if they were
coordinating or if there was any kind of
sense of something like that between
them well here's the thing they she had
her relationship with Adam while Josh
was having his relationship with mine so
they probably didn't talk about it too
much because they were probably both on
their phones on opposite ends of the
couch dming miners that's so weird yeah
I mean no wonder there was tension in
their relationship I mean the stuff was
going on behind the scenes if if you're
not paying attention to your significant
other because you're chatting with
Children online
that's
that's grounds for a failed relationship
and in my world at least
um
it's just weird I don't get it it's very
weird
um
and they would so ultimately
did this leave a lasting effect on you
that you were like friends with this
older guy that you confided in and then
all of a sudden he just disappeared and
left you like discarded nothing did that
did that hit you pretty hard like
growing up into maturity
yes but then I had my Redemption
um my Lord and Savior Colleen Christ
came and swooped in and she was the hero
of the day and she trauma bonded with me
and yeah yeah we both hate Josh right we
have so much in common so when did she
reach out to you how did she know to
reach out to you well I reached out to
her because it was
um
Corey had posted on Facebook back in
2018 early in the year that they were
going to need help on the upcoming tour
and I dm'd him and I was like hey I'm
interested and he was like uh okay we'll
talk and I was like well forget him I
don't want to go through him I want to
go through Colleen but I didn't have her
number yet and she didn't DM me a lot so
it was kind of hard to get in contact
with her however I still lived in
Illinois I was going to see a show in
Wisconsin that weekend with my mom
and she would just cover my tickets I
didn't pay for tickets I think I all the
years I've supported her maybe paid for
like two to three tickets
um and
my mom and I we went to were meet and
greet just like everybody else but we
stayed uh towards the back of the line
that's what people would do to get their
extra few minutes with her if you were
like a cookie a queef or whatever she
wanted to call you and that day I
decided to
put myself out there and just tell her
to her face hey saw Corey posted about
this
Count Me In I want to do it
to my surprise she was like absolutely
that's the best idea ever she was like
you know my show you know me you know
the ins and outs why didn't I think of
this and I was like damn I thought you
were gonna say maybe but this is better
than I expected and that's how I got
wound up in it I want to say that was
like March of 2018 and then like a month
later I had started going on tours with
her that's when you guys that's when you
guys bonded like in person while you
guys were touring yes yes but she used a
lot of my trauma with Josh to bond with
me because her friend Corey was being
straight up abusive to me the entire
tour and whenever I would go to her and
cry to her and be like I am absolutely
miserable like this is not what I wanted
this is not what I expected I want to go
home
she'd be like no like please we just
have to make sure tour goes as smoothly
as possible he's an [__] I'll talk to
him
and then there was one specific time
where I told her I was like I feel like
I'm walking on eggshells and she looked
at me and she was like
are you just saying that you were you
just saying that you feel like you're
walking on eggshells
is exactly how I felt when I was in my
relationship with her ex Joshua and then
she started talking about him and I was
like
are we not gonna query oh okay sure yes
Josh we hate him great and then it was
just kind of like
the end of that conversation was okay
well glad you feel better we both hate
Josh and
what now I went back to the bus they
went back to their hotel rooms what did
my real price got revoked your what got
revoked my room writes oh you lost your
room right what is that
what was that what does that mean
it means what it sounds like uh I
basically it was like one of night two
or three we were like in Albany New York
and we after shows we'd get on the bus
load everything up drive to a hotel get
there about 2 A.M
unload if you wanted to sleep on the bus
or wanted a room you you had the option
why would anybody choose to sleep on the
bus
well Mr DeSoto is an interesting one and
there were a few nights where he
actually he enjoyed sleeping on the bus
I will say very comfortable like a
little cocoon Tempurpedic it was it was
nice it wasn't the worst but okay you
know it's
one thing to have a little cocoon versus
a queen mattress an actual room and
there was an evening where we got to a
location super late was still trying to
figure out the dynamic of rooms uh two
of Colleen's crew members got a room me
and Corey were paired up and then
obviously Colleen and Eric had shared a
room
and
um me and Corey we had discussed early
on that
the way it would work is
we would either share the room or if a
person says I want it tonight
sure I never planned on doing that
because it was Corey De Soto I'm not
going to try to fight him for a room if
he ever told me I want it for myself I
was gonna respectfully bow out and sleep
on the bus
um that's just kind of how it was
presented to me so this night we park I
poke my head out of my little bus cocoon
and I see that him and Colleen are
standing in like the little living area
and I get out we're at the hotel so I
see that um the tour manager had left
out room keys for all of us and I see
Corey and Johnny
I grab mine I go up to the hotel or
actually I asked Corey I was like do you
you care if we share the room and he was
just kind of he mumbles a lot
um
and it's just inaudible mumbles it's not
talking it's literally mumbling so I was
like okay then he went in his little bus
cocoon and shut the curtain and I was
like
baby sleeping on the bus tonight okay so
I went up to the room and then I texted
him and I said
I didn't realize I grabbed both room
keys do you want to sleep in the room I
wasn't clear on your answer on the bus
if you want a key I can run down and get
you one or
I'll open the door for you like I was
giving options and he was like no it's
fine just make sure that you're awake
early enough in the morning because I'll
run up and get a key so I can get in the
hotel gym and I was like okay
flash forward to the next morning
she comes up to the hotel room and I get
a knock on the door I open the door and
I greet him just hi good morning and he
doesn't say much but again sometimes he
just doesn't talk or he mumbles so I was
like okay and I went and I sat back on
the bed and I was like how are you like
what's up and he wasted no time he just
immediately started screaming at me
talking about I stole the room from him
and he has worked his way up to the top
he has seniority
um he would lick a toilet bowl clean for
Colleen like he deserves the room I
don't and I was like mortified Beyond
um and he I was like Corey I think this
is a misunderstanding can we please talk
and he stormed out of the room and
slammed the door on me and I just sat in
the bed for a few minutes
it had a little bit of a panic attack
cried ran out of the hotel ran to a park
nearby and I called my mom and that was
the first of many phone calls to my mom
where I was like I don't know if this
was a good idea
so they didn't they no longer let you
stay in hotel room after that yeah
Colleen had texted me and I had um
shared these DMS or not DM's text
messages then
um on Tick Tock a few nights ago
and a lot of people glossed over that
conversation because I don't think they
remembered a whole lot of the context
behind it but she was like it was
totally my mistake I didn't explain the
situation right to you I love you and
it was just all deflection and and then
I ended up
um having a in-person conversation with
her because I had explained that I was
it bothered me and I wanted to know the
correct way to approach Corey because I
felt it was necessary to apologize to
him and
um
yeah when we got to the next Theater
which oddly enough is I think the night
that Becky was there if it was the
Syracuse interesting yeah full circle it
all Loops in
um that night I had apologized to Corey
for that incident and Colleen had told
me in the conversation I had with her
prior or after the apology she was like
I think it's just best if you don't use
the room anymore and you can sleep in my
bed on the back of the bus if you want
which felt weird to me I didn't
I tried once and I was like not a fan
and then um
she just tossed me off to our lighting
sound Guy tour manager's room who they
also started sharing with the bus driver
so it was like four grown dudes trying
to get every minute of sleep we could
try to shower within like an hour time
frame it was impossible so I ended up
just um
not having a shower in the morning I I
had to wait till we would get to the
venue and I would choose what days it
was necessary versus not and if I had
time before work great if I didn't I'd
wait till the show was over and I would
shower before we got back on the bus in
the venue public showers like the gym
shower essentially so you were you
mentioned that you were backstage during
the show where the incident happened to
Becky that's that's interesting I I want
to talk to you Becky and maybe we can
all just discuss
um
so I I can't see you Becky I don't know
if that's the thing that you do
oh yeah thank you hi hi so I have it set
to auto switch so once somebody starts
talking it'll switch to them
um
so at the time how old were you at the
time you went to the show
uh 16. 16. and were you uh you were a
hardcore uh Colleen fan at the time yeah
and so you showed up and you wore uh can
you explain it how you explained it you
wore us like a skirt or something you're
trying to get her to pick you for this
porn segment
um yeah so I wore a romper
um because like I was saying she usually
picked girls that were wearing like a
little bit of more revealing clothing to
go up on stage for that bit
um but honestly like I've worn it before
it was just something I owned and
I didn't really think much of it anyways
so you get called up there I find it
really interesting that Johnny was
backstage because I kind of want to know
what was the reception of the crew
backstage but essentially Colleen called
you up for a yoga bit
and um well it was first a try not to
laugh bit and then it was a yoga
challenge so there was like two
different segments so just walk me
through how she how she guided you
through that experience
just
called me up from the audience it's
um
and when I got on stage I don't remember
if this was before or after the
um try not to laugh challenge but I know
Johnny was talking about how he saw it
too I remember
Pauline's eyes widened quite a lot when
she realized that I
wasn't
um wearing like pants or anything so
obviously what is what is it you think
that was going through her mind when she
noticed that
well I thought at the time that it was
just her being like uh oh like we have
to pick somebody else I honestly
expected that she was gonna send me off
the stage when
um she looked at me like that but
obviously she didn't so what do you
think of what did mean uh looking back
um well Johnny and I have talked about
this and I don't know we both kind of
think that
that she
saw it as an opportunity to make it more
funny somehow
okay so what happened
um so we did the try not to laugh
challenge which had four people on stage
and then after that she sent two people
off stage and then it was me and this
other guy
and um
sorry my voice is cracking
um I was before the guy so basically she
had like a picture of the yoga pose on
the screen behind
um behind her and she said okay like lay
down in this position
and
yeah and I did it because I I mean I
wasn't gonna say no like I loved her so
much yeah
um
but I remember thinking I was like this
is not good like I am not wearing enough
enough clothes for this this is really
bad and
um
I wasn't really sure like what she was
gonna do exactly with my legs at that
point because I like I saw that in the
picture they were open but I wasn't sure
if like she was gonna do that or
whatever
um but yeah then she spread them open I
remember I was just really scared
because the Romper was like falling off
completely basically and I remember just
like thanking God that I was wearing um
shorts under it but they those shorts
also didn't like really fit me right so
I was worried that like she would also
be able to see something and that was
like haunting me because she was someone
that like I looked up to a lot and was
like big in my life and I was like I
don't want you seeing anything this is
weird did it when she was doing it did
it feel like why like inappropriate or
were you just kind of
it I mean it was normal yeah but
I would say
the excitement of Connor being on stage
had worn off at that point because I had
already been up there for a few minutes
for the try not to laugh challenge so it
definitely did feel like inappropriate
in that moment
and so Johnny backstage was there a
reaction to that
yes I was actually explaining to Becky
that it wasn't a good evening on the bus
the atmosphere was very strange because
when it was happening Becky has
mentioned that her eyes widen and I
remember it just it didn't feel like uh
oh no look at what this girl is wearing
type of reaction it felt like you know
she was squeezing the mic kind of like
Yay like this is a this is a thumbnail
waiting to happen these are clicks like
that's the way her mind works that's
that's the way her family's mind works
so I think as Becky said it was an
opportunity however backstage behind the
curtain what Corey De Soto does for her
shows is hit a space bar on a MacBook
Pro for an hour and and do a a slide
it's PowerPoint and
um
I would usually just say like stand next
to him or side stage and then we would
also I would perform with him on stage
we would run out sometime so I had cues
and everything but yeah so for this
segment we're standing there her eyes
wide in Becky walks up on stage and we
could never see who she was choosing
until they were on stage so we see it's
Becky and we know who Becky is she had
been to a book signing the week prior
she had been to a few other shows like
that's how you know these conversations
were had with these young girls because
sometimes it wasn't always publicly in
DMS online it was during that meet and
greet moment at the end when the the
fans who were like the the well-known
Twitter fans would wait at the end and
have those few extra moments they'd be
like Colleen like is this is this okay
like is this good for the porn bit is
this good for this bit and she'd be like
oh my God yes like I'll look for you in
the audience I'll try to find you and
that was the dynamic so these girls
would just try to dress skimpier and
skimpier and it wasn't because they
like like the victim blaming and the
[__] shaming of children in the misogyny
is beyond
Becky was coerced to wear this outfit
for the porn bed which we could get into
but let that when you say coerced what
uh was that somehow did she was there an
expectation that you were gonna wear
that Becky
um not personally
but I know that have happened to other
people I remember I honestly don't
remember exactly what happened but like
Johnny was saying I had been at the book
signing the week before and something
happened my memory is a little bit fuzzy
but I told her I was going to like one
of the next shows and because something
had happened she was like oh it's okay
like that that happened I'll try to call
you up on stage or something but that
was the extent of it okay yeah
okay so but like I I wondered when I
heard your story if there was like a
stage manager or director or producer or
somebody back there to like keep the
show on the rails that was like what the
[__] is going on
see the thing is yes and also I wanted
to clarify too what I meant by fans
being like coerced or like lured into
these situations it's because if you
dress a certain way you get to have a
stage moment with your Idol who wouldn't
want to have pictures of them on stage
with Miranda Sings before I worked for
her I used to have my hand in the air
waving her down trying to get called up
and I was called up I did the Miranda
Sings birth bit with her when I was 17
years old in Chicago
um so
it was your goal to get called up on
stage you would do what had to be done
get called up and that's even she used
to spit water and like milk on fans and
like you would degrade yourself to have
your moment with this woman okay I see
so and Becky that sounds like it rings
true like you you Dr you wore that with
the expectation that you're probably
gonna get called on
yes yeah yeah so yeah
so yeah but to answer your question
about like the dynamic backstage we did
have a tour manager we that we there was
a team and me and Corey when we saw what
was going down we were kind of side
eyeing each and Corey I am not a query
apologist but me and Corey were looking
at each other kind of like
uh
modify it right she's smart like I
thought of all things she could have
been like you guys look at what this
girl's wearing look at the picture I
cannot do that and then she would have
gotten a laugh but instead she laid
Becky on the ground and I don't care if
Becky was wearing a pantsuit you do not
do that position to a child
even more so because I found a video of
her way back in the day for some reason
she was watching something where someone
did that yoga position or whatever and
she stated in an old video that it looks
like a sexual position so why are you
incorporating that position into your
show that is all ages according to you
and according to the box office yeah
yeah and her reaction after the fact she
got off stage and it was the instant hot
topic what had happened to Becky that oh
they talked about it afterwards
absolutely
drama yeah oh oh yeah they talked about
it backstage or during the show
no no no backstage okay that was the
okay interesting so what were people
saying about it well Colleen got off of
off of stage and was kind of like giddy
about it kind of like oh my god did you
see what she was wearing and we were
kind of like yeah you gonna do something
about that like you need to either
remove I I think it was Eric especially
because you know I had to kind of know
my place I was already getting the
seniority thing held over my head so I
couldn't say much unless it was things
involving me but you know Eric if memory
serves me right he was pissed the tour
manager if memory serves me right was
like I want this segment removed or
changed and she thought it was filmed
for YouTube
what's that it was filmed for YouTube is
that what he wanted removed
no from the show oh okay yeah she acts
like it's so hard to take things out of
the show again let me remind you Corey
literally just sits there and presses a
space bar on a PowerPoint slide all it
takes is one second to either delete a
slide or replace that portion with like
a quick segment
Becky you were there with a parent right
uh I was at the family friend oh okay
what did they uh did they notice it did
were they like what the [__] was that
did they know that something had
happened
um they didn't they didn't really say
anything about it
and yeah
interesting
but you had mentioned that when you were
leaving the venue you felt like when you
say men were looking at you mean like
the dads that were there with their kids
uh yeah because mostly like any older
men over like 20 would be a dad although
I do remember that there was this one
guy who was really looking at me who did
not seem to be a dad he was like
probably like 26 or something and he was
just by himself and at this venue you
had to leave
um like the audience place by going down
an elevator so I was in the elevator
with like my friend and then other
mirandas but then there was like
some guys who were
definitely look at me that in ways they
were not looking at me before it was
pretty gross that's weird
so I I guess uh Johnny I want to ask you
I want to move on to
um I want to talk to Oliver A little bit
about these these texts exchanges with
Trent
uh her brother
and um Johnny had you ever met Trent uh
while working
for not
working I actually had a friendship as a
minor with Trent where I had hung out
with him once when I had turned 18 with
a few other friends we were doing a road
trip in California and we stopped in
Santa Barbara and
she made plans with him to hang out and
I was like okay so we did and it was
fine
um but in hindsight very weird even
though we were adults at that time we
had developed this bond with him as kids
and
um
it just didn't really add up and make
sense
um and then he also would go to shows
all the time he'd be active in shows I
heard someone say that
it's been said that he never was at
shows but he was well Colleen's or
somebody had said that right or Colleen
said that she he wasn't at a lot of
shows or yeah I read that yeah but
that's not true is it no no that could
be debunked because I even posted a
picture
um of Corey you can see in the
reflection it's like Colleen and she's
like smiling and she's reading us fans
but Corey didn't realize he's in the
reflection and he's just pouting but the
other side of the reflection you see
Trent and that picture is from 2013 or
yeah 2013. so he's been going to shows
forever he's been a part of the the
Family scene he yeah so Oliver I want to
ask you how did um
how did you first get in touch with
Trent
uh his computer died but he is the group
one so I can see everyone yeah
um yeah Trent is her older brother right
is he what's their age difference yes
you know honestly I'm not sure I think
Trent is well actually wait Oliver said
how how much older was Trent than him
like 10 years maybe Oliver's
um of course I know 20 years that
wouldn't make sense 20 years older so I
believe Trent would be 39 now almost 40.
yeah famous birthday says 38 and
um okay 36. okay yeah I believe Trent is
the oldest or maybe their their brother
Christopher is the oldest then it goes
Trent then it goes Colleen and then
Rachel is the youngest what do you guys
think about this I noticed that in the
chat log with Oliver Trent says
something like oh my family says I'm not
supposed to be talking to fans
I find that really odd especially
considering that he kept attending shows
so they knew he had this tendency and he
was still allowed to attend the shows I
don't know if you
yeah stood out to you
well they also had conversations like
that on bus tour because he's been in
hot water plenty of times
um bus to where I remember we were in an
Uber to Mall of America one day and I
use these specific details because I
feel like it's important in case Colleen
or any of them are watching this and
need a refresher
um we were on our way to the mall and I
remember she had been talking about
um it was kind of like the generation in
between Colleen's cookies and the
weenies there was a generation in
between there and some of them have kind
of spoken but
um a lot of them haven't yet maybe
um but there were a lot of group members
in there having issues with Trent with
Trent yeah and he had a history of being
a creep to to the to kids oh yeah he
called me uh he he granted me the name
Xmas sucker when I was 16 because I in
his words I was sucking on a sucker I
was minding my business chatting my
friends on Tinychat and I happened to be
eating a candy cane
crazy and he kept calling you Xmas
sucker he even changed my caller ID
somehow I called my job a couple of
years ago in 2020 and my boss the next
time I came in said so why when you call
people it comes up as Xmas sucker okay
um
no I wait
um so Oliver now that you're back I
wanted to ask you so um how did you
first get in touch with Trent how did
you guys connect
uh right so basically at the time when I
was a big Colleen stand back in the day
um everyone wanted follows from not only
her but also her family so
I just like I dm'd all the or not DMS
sorry I just like I tweeted all the
other family members I tweeted Trent
asking him for a follow
um and he did follow me
um and it didn't take long for him to
start replying to my tweets and it
wasn't tweets I tweeted at him I don't
think I really tweeted at him that much
like just for like out of nowhere
um but he would respond to like a lot of
my tweets and these are mostly just
tweets that I was tweeting out to like
my friends that were my age that um I
made through the fandom
um
but eventually I was like oh well he
keeps like responding to me a lot like I
wonder if he would answer a DM because
also at the time people would want to
have DMS from the family members too it
would be something that they would try
to like aim for you know because that's
what everyone wanted they wanted to talk
to the Ballinger Family and so I
messaged him
um I was like oh do you respond to DMS
and then he was like sometimes
um
and then I think I may have messaged him
one or two more times
um myself first
um
and then but then after that he started
messaging me first
um a lot of times it would be like
I would tweet about something and then
he would like message me he would DM me
about that tweet or something and then
start a conversation I don't know but
anyway
um but then it started to become more
frequent because it was kind of like
scattered like for the first couple
months or so
but then it quickly turned into like a
almost everyday thing and then became an
everyday thing so how old were you at
that time uh 13 when it first started
wow
and he was like 30 right uh or roughly
he was 33 when I was wow
yeah holy [__] and even at 13 you could
tell that this was inappropriate or how
did you feel like what
so at the time I was
I was at first I was like really excited
because like this is something that
anyone in the fandom would really like
you know they would want a DM from one
of the ballingers
um so I thought it was like really cool
at first and then after like a little
bit it kind of turned into confusion I
was like why does he care about me in my
life so much like I I was confused and
didn't really understand but I also
trusted him because I idolized Colleen
so much and he was her brother so I
didn't really question it that much at
first
um but then later on I started to kind
of get uncomfortable but even at the
time I was uncomfortable like it was
hard to like I didn't really know how to
sit with those feelings because I was
like well anyone in this fandom would
love to message him and I'm being
ungrateful or whatever you know so I
would just ignore a lot of red flags and
a lot of those feelings I had well you
were 13. yeah
and also because
and so um
as he he as the conversation went on
because I read the chat logs you can see
how it gets becomes more obviously
flirtatious
um and it culminated when he was trying
to I forget if he was trying to meet you
or get on the phone with you or
something and you're like I don't think
my mom would would allow that I don't
think my mom would like that yeah so
that was when he
um that was when he gave me his phone
number and he said that I could text him
if I ever needed to or wanted to just
talk or whatever
um and yeah that that's when
red flags that I had been ignoring
I was ignoring all those red flags but
this was a red flag that I felt like I
couldn't ignore and I was already
it had been months and months
um
that I had been talking to him and at
this point
I was already kind of trying to plan my
escape from him if that makes any sense
like I didn't want there to be this hard
stop because I didn't want
there would be some sort of drama or
like I don't know I was just I wanted to
slowly just kind of like fade out of his
life if I could and why um why was it at
the time you wanted to do that I just
felt really uncomfortable and a lot of
times his conversations would stress me
out and I'd be like I felt expected to
talk to him like multiple times a day
for like Walker's time did you did you
feel at the time that he was trying to
hit on you did that even occur to you
honestly that didn't really occur to me
at the time
um but I still felt like uncomfortable
about it and like it was weird
um
but yeah when he gave me his number it
was like this is gonna be ten times
harder to just like fade out if we
switch to text and we're not on DMS
anymore and so I don't know why that's
what made me panicked but that is what
made me panicked and then of course
after some thinking about it I was like
you know this is not appropriate either
um and yeah three days later he blocked
me because I then told him that I
thought the whole entire relationship in
itself was inappropriate he blocked you
yeah how did you feel when you blocked
you that's almost an admission of guilt
I mean there if you read the the logs
which we've lived over it's just like
he's just a pedophile like I even know
how to sugarcoat that
but um how did you feel when he blocked
you
um it was a lot of mixed emotions
because I was like kind of
still feeling relieved like for that I
wasn't gonna have to that I got that
over with and I wasn't gonna have to
talk to him anymore
but also it was
like it was still like really like I
felt hurt like I don't know why I felt
her but I was like I understand I didn't
think that I didn't think that
we like
I just didn't want to be talking to him
one-on-one anymore I didn't think that
he was gonna like try to like block me
out entirely like you know but it almost
reveals it's kind of shocked it Reveals
His intentions really when he's like oh
I'm not gonna be able to meet up with
her and do anything with her then I
don't wanna I don't want to waste my
time talking to her anymore or him I'm
sorry yeah no I mean at the time I did
use she heard pronouns so I mean that
kind of makes sense but yeah I mean it
it was it was honestly weird and there
was a time where he was telling me that
I could go to
his apartment when I was older and stay
there yeah I saw that so yeah
so I
honestly like I'm trying I try not to
blame myself because I know it wasn't my
fault but I look back and I'm like how
did I not realize that that was so weird
like you were a child yeah that it's not
right that's not your part part of
what's so Insidious about child abuse
like that is that when we grow up and
look retrospectively back we look at it
through the lens as an adult and we
think how could I be so stupid but you
you can't really see it Through The Eyes
of a 13 year old again and uh it really
you know
it's just completely not your fault I
mean
you're you were literally a child you
know
so but it is it is interesting he he
must have been talking to other kids
like oh yeah he was he he was also and
not as often but he would talk to two of
my closest friends at the time and also
talk to them about oh wow it was weird
yeah like one time I wasn't responding
to him for a few hours and he was
basically like trying to get my other
friend to like make me respond to him
with this video he wanted I don't it was
the whole thing
um
so
do you think like looking back at how
all that played out
do you blame Colleen or any of them for
enabling him to have that interaction
with with kids
I mean I have mixed feelings about it
because obviously like
you know
Colleen did it do it herself obviously
it's like you know Trent it was
transactions um but I do believe that
you know she knew about that he was
doing these things and it seemed more
like she was more worried about
um
the it not getting out that he was being
this way then actually being concerned
that he was talking to underage people
and
looking back on that now that's like
kind of
that doesn't sit right with me well
she's the one that gave him the access
and yeah apparently he kept coming to
the shows and by all accounts it does
seem like they knew based on what he
told you about oh my family says I
shouldn't be talking to you
yeah I just feel like the negligence of
of giving him access to children
is borderline criminal I mean
it's crazy
yeah it is
really really wild because I know that
there was someone that he was that well
okay isn't a minor now but was a minor
when he first started talking to them
and still received the message
from him like right before all this
started coming like going down like
still trying to shut up wow
yeah wow
that's crazy so collectively when you
guys kind of look back on this period of
your of your lives like
even before all this uh started coming
out publicly were you guys feeling like
resentful and looking back on that just
feeling used and dirty I don't know how
to describe it
I mean for me personally something
really interesting that happened was I
had seen a Miranda sings show in January
up in Thousand Oaks because I live in
Orange County now
um it was a bad experience and leaving
it I had even run into
um
a fan of mine who I I mean I don't
consider her that anymore because I mean
I haven't worked on tour in years but I
had recognized this girl and so
I had run into her after the show and we
were just talking and I was like yeah I
think I'm gonna like pull back from all
of this and she was like what do you
mean and I was like like this world just
because it was terrible and then you
know months down the line
Adam's story is getting brought back up
and I already kind of like went or I
came out of that experience uh back in
January thinking I was going to slowly
remove myself completely from these
people just kind of like
trickle my way out and uh
didn't happen that way because I saw
Adam was talking about his story again
or I should say his story was being
talked about again
so he had to
defend himself and I just as much as it
was hurtful for me to see Colleen just
stand back and watch her friend be
really abusive towards me I felt like as
an adult in the situation I felt like I
had let Adam down a couple years ago by
not saying anything and so I feel like I
finally had the chance to do the right
thing for not only him but myself as
well and that's why I have been so
outspoken this time around because
the time before I had seen them months
ago was in 2019 physically I haven't
spoken with them too much they they
really have just paid me dust ever since
I busted my ass for them and
um the only time I really heard from
Colleen a lot is when Adam came out with
his video in 2020 I had texted her to
kind of you know be an adult in the
situation and be like yo what's up I
think you should make a statement and
say something and she let me know that
it was the same thing uh you know as
what's happening now that she was told
to stay quiet by whoever and
uh that it would just all go away if she
just didn't say anything
um yeah and she uh she chatted me up for
like two weeks I was like a therapist I
received more nudes of Trish okay yeah
that was that was another thing that you
were able to bring to like because that
the the allegation that she was sending
nude pictures of Trisha yeah her fans
was was like almost unbelievable I think
I know you got the screenshots and it
was like holy [__] yeah yeah it was that
was that was a conflicting thing because
I had found them on my laptop and I was
like
I gotta get these out but like I also
didn't have a way to privately contact
Trish it was a whole thing now I've
taken the pictures down because I don't
like they've served their purpose right
um but it was just in the moment
I just felt I felt so gaslit from not
only this woman but so many other people
in her Circle I just
I had to get it out there but part of me
was pissed that Trish hadn't made a
response yet and I was like well I know
a way that'll get her to and uh well
that's true so it did work yeah I just
really wanted people to take this
seriously and I knew especially with us
coming on this podcast and you know
history with Trish and everything like I
just I think it it's even more impactful
that we are speaking on this podcast
today and she just publicly denounced
this woman a few days back
um you wanted Trisha to be forced to
publicly denounce
Colleen which in some way I just wanted
I knew that Colleen was probably telling
Trisha behind the scenes that we were
full of it enough yeah and she was and
then I think it wasn't
with this situation at least I think I
was a bit irritated by that fact I was a
little irritated that Trish hadn't said
anything and not only Trish there's
plenty of other people who I think
should have said something by now who
haven't and that's just my personal life
you want to say name you want to name
names sure
um I think Joey Graceffa Daniel Prayed
uh Frankie Grande glozell green all
these people who constantly appeared and
were very active in her life should be
saying something because I know if I was
that tight-knit with a friend back in
the day and these allegations started
publicly coming out about them I'd be
the first to say y'all that's weird I'm
not about that life so what what kind of
statements would you be happy with them
uh to say about it
um honestly I think a statement could be
as much as an unfollow or just oh
publicly showcasing that you do not
support this person in a public light
anymore I think that's that's a
statement that says a lot or you know
people like Tyler Oakley wrote a a big
statement and put it on
um a streaming platform I believe uh at
the time I wasn't super thrilled with
this but in hindsight
um Grace has gone through a lot of [__]
right now so her and memory heart um
Grace how big and made me heart like
referred people over to Tyler's
um the announcement and said everything
he said we stand by it and I was kind of
like okay is that a cop-out again I'm
good with that it doesn't have to be
this huge formal thing
um it's just I think the ones who were
really really active
um in her life it's just a bit bizarre
to me to see them acting as if
nothing happened but then again like
what can you expect I mean it's just
more of a personal thing I just kind of
wish that these people would say
something but it's not necessarily
an expectation I'm holding on to and uh
Oliver and Becky did you guys leading up
to this whole
this whole outing of her and her family
were you guys holding on to some kind of
bitter feelings or thinking back on it
or did it all kind of come out now with
everybody talking about it
are you gonna go back here am I gonna go
I'll just say you're gonna go we're just
we're focused looking at each other I'll
go
um honestly I had been already kind of
like fading out of the Twitter fandom
not that I didn't like support her as a
person in the back of my mind and like
you know still like her as a person or
whatever but you know I was fading out
of the Twitter fandom as early as like
you know late 2019 like you know I
didn't last for too long even though it
felt like a really long time
um
but
yeah so I hadn't really I mean I still
had met her and like
gone to shows even as like as recent as
last year
um
but yeah
and but even when I did I would it was
just like I went because it felt like
the tradition it was like oh Colleen is
coming to my state there's no way I
can't go if she's coming to my state
like I you know like just felt like I
don't know I it wasn't like this big
like oh I'm so excited to see her like
it just you know it kind of felt like
did you see Trent at any of the shows oh
no I didn't I have never um met him I
think he only really went to like shows
that were local around the LA area
um I don't to my knowledge I don't think
he like traveled he never traveled with
them yeah he would only stay local
um California shows like SoCal and so
did you have like this moment you're
like oh [__] I have this experience with
Trent I should share this
yeah so I even made like a year ago like
a year or two ago I thought like you
know maybe I should share this to warn
people because I still like I knew from
other people that told me because of
course I couldn't see his tweets because
I was blocked but other people told me
that he was still interacting with like
people
um
on the timeline and I'm like I feel like
I should warn people but at the time you
know when I felt like that people
weren't going to perceive that very well
um
I don't I don't know why I just I didn't
think I thought people were probably
what happened to Adam in 2020 like right
yeah I didn't want to yeah and so I will
actually I wanted to ask you guys did
you were you guys on the receiving end
of any harassment and and [__] when you
guys shared your stories
I mean yeah
Becky's getting an emphatic nodding but
that's interesting to me because yours
came out recently right Becky
yeah
um
I going back to the original
conversation I think I kind of slowly
stopped being a fan of Colleen from that
night and especially when in 2020 those
racist videos came out because I'm part
Mexican and I saw that and I was like no
um but I
um posted originally about the stage
experience on like the Colleen snark
Reddit about seven months ago
and
um because I had been holding it in for
so long because I knew if I had said
anything it would have been it would
have been like an atom situation people
would have been like you're just
ungrateful because everybody wanted to
be a cult on stage
but yeah I did get a lot of support on
the Reddit page from that so then I kind
of was like well maybe I can talk about
it now when when like this happened just
all happened a few weeks ago
um so like I posted that Tick Tock and
stuff but
I've definitely gotten
in insane amount about backlash and
people like commenting on my body and
stuff of like when I was 16. it's just
it's crazy wow that's gross are they
calling fans or just random Tick Tock
freaks
takes a both I would say mostly random
Technologies yeah
yeah they're the worst yeah some people
have been really horrible to Becky like
I honestly feel so bad for like honestly
everyone just like give her all your
support like she could really use it
right now because there are so many
horrible people
yeah I hope it's not getting you too
much there I know there's a lot of
people who are appreciative and support
you and anyone who's saying anything bad
is just a total [__] troll freak I
always hate when I the people like
Colleen are in the situation like in
Colleen's or whatever it is when they
say that the victims are just like doing
it for clout it's like this is really
hard to do what you guys are doing this
is not fun
and like what you're saying you're
getting hate you're getting nasty
comments you're getting all kinds of
stuff
why would anybody do this for clout you
know yeah I'm like why why would I want
to be known for this
yeah
account and everything for this like I
don't really want people tracing it back
to who I am personally I mean it's
happened because this has been picked up
by so many like news outlets and stuff
but um Becky I want to ask you and
Colleen's video she described what she
did to you as a fart joke oh yes
is that accurate I don't know that
that's accurate
I mean when that like happened when
she's by my legs there was a sound
playing over the speakers so I guess it
was like that's what they wanted it to
be seen as I don't think
that's what she really intended it to be
like I think there was something more
Sinister under there in a sexual way
um I also saw somebody say that
they think it was actually a queef joke
which makes a lot more sense because she
was obsessed with something weird yeah
but yeah no TMZ made an article about it
and called it a fart joke and said
that's why people were
um canceling her so I assume that's
where she got it oh they actually there
they actually had a headline that she's
getting cancer over a fart joke yes this
was in like
stuff coming started coming out so yeah
I assume that's where she got it from
the song but yeah I was pretty upset
about it because I don't know it was
definitely something very vulnerable to
talk about and that I didn't want to
talk about for so long and
now it's kind of the joke of a very
large internet meme so
she completely minimized your experience
and yeah your experience was very valid
and it was very horrible
and thank you for speaking about it all
of you
yeah Olivia is a fallen fan so she's
right there oh yeah what do you guys
wish that she would have done like
instead of the ukulele song
anything anything about that okay
nothing would be better just just
nothing would be better than that yeah I
am actually curious what was your guys's
reaction when you saw the uke come out
I was like what the hell is she doing
with the ukulele like what is she doing
I've been taking a nap when it happens
and people were like texting me and were
like kind of briefing me on it
beforehand so I knew it was coming
she didn't even mention your experience
Oliver I like uh she that just basically
didn't even happen yeah no
no yeah
well and cl in closing I want to thank
the three of you guys for taking the
time and calling again I think it's a
great yeah is there anything you guys
want to share or anything uh that you
want to say before we part ways
um
supporting us is Johnny here
I don't know if you heard the questions
Johnny if you were watching or could
hear me no I'm sorry my internet gave
out for a second but I'm back I was just
asking what was everyone's reaction to
the uke video and
oh god oh
um well I'm glad no kidding
I I don't even know it was like the most
surprising
unsurprising thing I've ever experienced
it's kind of surreal isn't it yeah I
really did think I was gonna wake up the
next day and like be like whoa what a
fever dream but it never happened and
I'm still stuck in this nightmare
so I was asking uh the three of you as
we part ways if there's anything you
guys wanted to say
or uh anything else you want to talk
about before we left
did you guys go already no no no no I
think Becky was going to say something
yeah go for it to say thank you for
supporting us through this that's about
all I have to say thank you for sharing
your story and I hate that there's
freaks that are even saying anything
about you I hope you know it's not it's
not those people aren't real they're
just like weirdos like they're really
not real people they're just
yeah you have an army of people
supporting you it's a toxic gossip train
haters literally
I would say something similar as Becky
just thank you guys so much for giving
us the opportunity to speak and use our
voices and I appreciate the support not
only like here but also like behind the
scenes like thank you thank you thank
you yeah thank you for sharing your
story
yeah um if I could just add on to what
Becky and Oliver have said the support
is the most impactful meaningful thing
because I thought I might have had to
hold on to these stories forever and
take them to the Grave especially after
I had seen how Adam had been treated in
2020 and
I am I never ever ever thought that I'd
be telling them at all let alone so soon
and that they'd be so well received so I
just want to thank everybody as well I
want to thank Adam for being a child and
getting this started and and creating
this conversation we're able to have
today and
um thank you to all of you for giving us
the platform and the voices because
without you we would be shouting into an
abyss so it's appreciated and everybody
watching this right now and being
patient asking the questions
um I don't think this is going to be a
super linear thing there's going to be
confusion and there's going to be
questions that are had and hopefully we
have answers and yeah just thank you for
everything
yeah thank you all the viewers and
everything like you know it it has been
pretty hard
um and all three of us have been
receiving like hate all for three
different ways but you know it it makes
it
a lot easier to deal with when you have
also an overwhelming amount of support
and I don't think I would be able to
deal with the amount of transphobia and
just general hate that I've gotten if it
weren't for people like affirming me so
I'd like to thank them for that so yes
and thank you to the people who are
actually doing that
which uh thank you guys
um
if she does a ukulele part two what
would you guys like for her to discuss
no I'm just kidding you don't have to
answer how to break a ukulele how to
burn it how to dispose of One Forever
how to Never sing again
no because she ruins ruins the ukulele
like it's actually
ukuleles devastating and justice for the
ukulele
we need to reclaim the youth it was a
whole I mean before it was like uh
Somewhere Over the Rainbow yeah
now she's that's the only proper time
you know rainbows and [__] not anymore
if I made two I also um I just saw
Olivia pop up and I want to thank you
Olivia too for your diligence with the
first PowerPoint and showcasing all of
this and then reaching out to all of us
individually like I really appreciate it
a lot so thank you for all like thank
you so much thank you for telling your
stories it's
literally so important and I will always
be listening
thank you I wonder if there's more so
I'm worried about this Trent guy I don't
know he that guy's a menace man those
those chat logs were so disturbing yeah
yeah
yikes well anyway uh thank you guys so
much if you guys need anything let us
know okay we're in touch now
and um
yeah whatever you guys need all right
thank you thank you all right bye guys
bye thanks for calling bye bye
yes
All Aboard
There It Is All Aboard fart joke here's
some here's a palette cleanser from uh
my recommendations top secret tapes 911
the final moments of flight 93.
all right you want to see you want to
see something that was posted the
subreddit while we've been live today
yes please dreamly cursed yeah you ready
here we go this is
[Music]
whoa that's seamless
you guys why is that so good
I agree that's extremely cursed wait
that's so seamless Dan is you guys are
making the same face right why is that
it's the same face Dan is calling what
have you done Ben this is tragic
also I'm having a bit of a a crisis
right now I've been frantically
searching my old personal emails for the
last few minutes going back to 2014
because
when I forget I forget which of the
three said it but one of them was saying
how these people that were all
associated with Colleen need to
apologize and they listed off like a
bunch of the those old YouTubers that
were part of that crew or whatever and
it's hit me like a lightning bolt I
think I actually shot something for
Colleen in like 20. really yeah and I
didn't even remember even like
I don't know I I have to go back and
look I definitely shot something with a
bunch of the people that they listed off
and something in my brain is telling me
that Colleen was one of them huh
yeah I'll figure it out and come back
with the proof on Wednesday but it's
tripping me out a little bit uh the um
yeah a few of the names jumped out like
glozzilla remember that's the girl who
used to wear that was one of them
absolutely yeah with the cinnamon
challenge yes
she he's one of the ones he was saying
should
yeah
Colleen's like main core friend group
especially like towards 2012 was like
Todrick Hall who has his own like bad
person allegations now but um Todrick
GloZell Joey Graceffa Joey graceffa's
ex-boyfriend I can't remember his name
right now that's the only reason why I
called him that
um but yeah those are the people he
listed off got it when we were starting
YouTube GloZell was I was like what is
this I kind of remember looking on
Cinnamon right yeah
that's choking on Cinnamon videos it was
huge
hitting me right now right yeah and you
know what another one that in the past
you've complained about and you're like
who watches this is that guy flula yeah
oh yeah
you still see blue was another one that
I shot with at YouTube space wait where
did we see flula yesterday oh on the
case on the cake show yeah
[Music]
I know they used to collab I don't know
if they're actually friends
oh actually I do want to say I want to
apologize to Oliver real fast I said she
Oliver goes as a he or they right right
yeah Oliver uses here they yeah so sorry
Oliver that's my bad we love you love
you Legend
um and um
what is glozzil up to anyway
GloZell I know that she had a baby a few
years ago oh wow when is the baby doing
the cinnamon challenge I'm pretty
positive uh
Colleen met the baby
don't let her near that baby
uh
so anyway yeah uh thank you to them I
appreciate the call and what an episode
what a comeback this is our comeback
episode we are back yes
um you're so bad
cheers my dude we've been going for
almost five hours so are you [__]
serious I'm [__] serious five
somebody said I saw they're like I don't
care what it there's comments on the
server but they're like please don't be
a whole upset about Colleen
and I was like great they're already
coming for me I didn't even start yet
and then someone was like I don't care
what it is as long as it's like five
hours so there you go you guys got the
five hour episode there you go and thank
you for the uh incredible viewership I'm
so glad that you guys are all here
engaged uh we got a whole great
salute of episodes that come work back
we are running now to the end of the
year maybe
that's it did we pass 90k I saw that
yeah
we almost hit 100K at one point
crazy wow that's so uh amazing thank you
guys for being here um no crashes that's
how we got so many viewers well and you
know what's funny though they did seem
to fix the crash I don't hopefully we're
not jinxing it by saying that because I
did not see that throughout the episode
however the chat was still glitching and
having problems as long as people
weren't crashing I don't care about the
chat froze and just completely stopped
uh several times throughout the episode
today
it's nice thank you thank you guys um
whenever you take a break you always
leave and you're like is anyone going to
watch this when we come back
less so now than back when we were doing
like the main thing but it's nice to see
everybody still here
thank you guys this Friday I won't be
missing the show because we have a photo
shoot at Teddy fresh that I
need to be present at so just a heads up
that that's why I thought I should join
today and I'm glad I did because what a
show
[Applause]
I also will not be here Friday as well
oh yeah me neither yeah me too it's just
me yeah
I have a wedding I have to uh just me
huh you got this and uh thank you to all
the supporters and members and
everything I really appreciate the
members thank you guys so much for
supporting the show
it helps so much and I will see you
members tomorrow
my doctor's appointment's at um
three so I'll probably start early maybe
start at like one and go for
or like 12 30 go for an hour and a half
or something
but I'll see you uh the members tomorrow
and everybody else for the main episode
we will be back on Wednesday
and there's still so much left there's
some unfinished business that we got to
take care of on Wednesday but so I love
other than what oh yeah the the or the
back trailer
the back chair layer
yeah we have a lot to get to so stay
tuned everybody
um and thank you again all aboard
this rip Zach yeah thank you
Jay
jugging down the tracks of
misinformation
[Music]
got some dreams
chugging down the tracks of
misinformation the toxic gossip train
you gotta Runway ticket to manipulation
station toxic got some dreams
[Music]
rumors look like bags if you don't find
the gaps I won't survive the cries hi
everyone I've been